and possibly the most
shocking thing out of the derek chauvin
trial
in minneapolis so far george floyd's
girlfriend
told the court as she was being
questioned by the defense
that this one of the state's key
witnesses a guy named
a guy named maurice lester hall
was george floyd and her dealer and he
was supposed to be testifying as one of
the key witnesses for the state
abruptly apparently just the day before
this guy
shocked the court by saying he wasn't
going to testify he wasn't going to be a
witness
in fact he's pleading the fifth and this
is just one
big factor in the defense that we've
seen so far that really makes it seem
like my friends this is going to be
well i'll put it this way if there is a
reasonable jury that's following the
evidence the same way i am as i'm
watching the court same as them and
hearing a lot of the same evidence
boy it sure does sound at the very least
like reasonable doubt across the board i
don't even think manslaughter can stick
i really don't you've got
we're gonna get into this story but
there's just so much to break down a few
months prior to this incident uh
incident george floyd had od'd and gone
to the hospital complaining of the exact
same symptoms
video showing george floyd saying i
can't breathe before he was even
restrained
i think the jury is going to see
reasonable doubt unless politics gets in
the way
so we're going to talk about all this
stuff and joining us today is none other
than
michael malus thank you for having me
tim you get shouted out too much on this
show so we're like just tell him to come
over
red rover red rover regardless right
over say his name too many times
i'm like beetlejuice and candy man yeah
bees bees bees all right
and ian's here i'm so glad you're here
mike um yes and i'm sporting our new
i am a gorilla diamond hands t-shirt let
me see if i can get this in the frame
there we go
perfect the gorilla is back and he's
made a lot of money indeed
well because he knew not to stop sell
his stonks too soon
he had diamond hands but i suppose like
you're not supposed to sell ever
i guess he waited till i got to the moon
and then sold or something i don't do
jokes whatever it's a gorilla with money
buy the shirts teamcast.com shop and you
can get yours
we've actually sold a ton of these
people love the wall street gorilla
thing
he's very charming he is yeah he's
supposed that's right a nice smile
and he knows the truth about building
seven is that what yeah he's at it
because he's in new york all right all
right well that's what that's a
reference to
what i'm a gorilla no it isn't it was
the ishmael book
yeah but that was alex jones saying it
on this show oh i get it i get it i got
what you're saying right right
he was the eye oh i'm a gorilla the the
the secret is
the origin i i don't know if i should
say this the original drawing
was was proposed as alex jones sang it
and i said we can't do that
because that's alex jones like his
likeness his business we can't
that's true yeah has to be an actual
gorilla but the original proposal that i
got was like so should we make an alex
alex jones saying i was like no we can't
do that it was uh you know hey
it's actually just a gorilla now there
you go we got lydia she's i'm also in
the corner uh me and michael always get
up to newgood when he's here we have a
lot of you were texting lydia
during one of our episodes getting her
to shout you out
she just shout me out my good friend
ethan supple who is who i am
who i adore yeah uh he was on yeah pals
with you
and i thought it'd be funny if she asked
what do you guys like best about michael
and you all had easy answers i'm very
likable that's right
the most likeable my friends uh we're
gonna get serious and before we do go to
timcast.com and become a member
because you will get access to exclusive
members only segments
we are very very close to rolling out
the brand new website i gotta tell you
it looks amazing
this company that's putting stuff
together it's like it's actually fancy
looking
and i'm actually i actually just went
over a treatment this is like basically
the
the elevator pitch for a tv series which
we might actually
produce because we're going to get into
the business of making culture and
making shows and
just being regular people that make fun
things and get away from the weird
culty woke stuff so go to teamgas.com
become a member we got a bunch of
special bonus segments but it really
does help in the events that in the
event we get banned or whatever
this is where we'll have all of our
content and we got a lot more to come so
working on the vlog the chickens are
doing their chicken stuff we're going to
make chicken can
we're going to put a live camera in the
chicken city so that people can just
tune in for no reason just watch the
chickens it's so cute
hilarious but they had they have kitten
cam they've had goats they have an
aquarium camp it's relaxing it's like
asmr right you'll get to watch the
chickens drink the water turn around
take a dump right in their water dish
and then start drinking from it again
it's brilliant stuff watching chickens
every day i swear to god how do they
drink they have to like put a mouthful
in them
yeah they they like bite the water a
little bit nibble it and then they flip
their heads back yeah
and then like one of them will like
stand up and pulse wings out and then
just like dump right in the water
and then turn around and start drinking
again like right in the same spot it's
amazing how these things survived as
long as they did well what about no no
no no okay i'm gonna get all
animal here okay uh
gorillas i worked on a book called the
paleo manifest with john durant i edited
it
and there were gorillas in captivity and
the problem with the gorillas is they
kept
eating their poop or they weren't eating
their poop they weren't the problem is
because you're eating vegetation it's
hard to break down
so rabbits cows other animals they eat
their poop to get the more nutrition
hold on rabbits don't literally eat
their poop it's called something else
and apparently it's like there's like a
gland next to it or something i can't
remember i was reading about this
because we had rabbits a few years ago
they do eat their poop
but it's not the same thing as poop sure
it comes out of their butt though yeah
whereas cows you know huck it back up
and then chew on it and swallow it again
okay go to timcats.com because
apparently it's a great conversation yes
and you'll get exclusive segments like
this laugh after the show we'll have a
members only segment so so go ahead and
do it
let's get serious guys all about chicken
husbandry chicken husband we don't have
a rooster and so it's really funny when
when like the cat walks up the chickens
know what to do
there's no rooster to be like yo get
inside run the cats i'm gonna get
serious did you know there's a whole
big controversy about uh chickens and i
think it's in europe that they just
banned or in japan
one of these countries and chickens
there's this book called inside the
memory palace i think it was called or
something like that the point is when a
chicken is born a chick
right all the people who breed chickens
for food they only want the females
because the roosters are tough yeah so
there are people whose job it is
to take a newly hatched chick squeeze
it's
whatever it's junk and it looks very
very different
slightly different excuse me when it's a
male or female
in that one second they throw it into
the shredder grinder or the meat grinder
or they put it aside and that's their
whole job yeah yeah people were
complaining adam writes people you're
killing 50
of the chicken population and they just
recently made it illegal wow so now
they're going to have all these surplus
roosters and the other thing i know
about chickens
i feel like joey tribiani when he got
the the encyclopedia and he got volume c
the other thing is um what was i going
to say i forgot about something about
roosters are hilarious man chickens are
funny they're just funny to watch them
do their chicken thing
they're great they they run up to us
because we like there's so many stink
bugs out here we just flick them in and
then they
they dude it's like it's the size of a
whole pizza to these things you know
what i mean
and now when we walk in they run up to
us and then we try and like go and grab
them they freak out and run screaming
so it's just funny anyway let's talk
about you're supposed to say they're
running around like chickens with their
heads not cut off
yes not cut off you said they're bigger
now they're they're not chicks anymore
they're pullets pullets
my friends smash the like button
subscribe hit the notification bell
we're really close to breaking a million
how did we just deviate for five minutes
on chicken tacos i don't know
it's so good let's talk about what's
going on with the chauvin trial check
this out
we got this from the daily mail george
floyd's girlfriend breaks down in court
as she reveals they were both addicted
to opioids
and the drugs were sold by his friend
who refuses to testify at derek chovan's
murder trial
i'm just gonna break this down for you
this guy maurice lester hall a key
witness for the state filed a shock
notice on wednesday
stating that he plans to invoke the
fifth against self-incrimination
okay the defense asked this this woman
okay right george floyd's girlfriend
did george floyd see maurice lester hall
a lot did he hang out with him a lot and
she was like not a lot
every so often yeah
every so often uh-huh she didn't like
him she apparently said in an affidavit
i think that they showed her the paper
saying you told the fbi this
i think was the fbi that floyd had
purchased the pills
from this guy and so here we have it
let's think about this
what's the kind of person that you're
friends with that you only see from time
to time
who have who sold you drugs in the past
you what do you call that
what do you call it i call him tim okay
if any if anyone would it's gonna be you
not me
like a like a drug dealer yeah yeah
that's that's exactly what it sounded
like
yeah i got
judge cahill said in september back when
they're like preparing this stuff
the evidence that was presented by
defense it looks like floyd
had a tablet in his mouth the judge said
that
so let's let's put these things together
the dude maurice lester hall is in the
shop
on surveillance footage and the daily
mail pulled one of the clips
and he's dropping something in floyd's
hand the clerk says
floyd looked like he was under the
influence he was like having trouble
speaking slurring his words
floyd gets in the vehicle he's with this
guy
then we have what is this then we have
uh that is so
welcome to windows yeah i just upgraded
from windows
uh 8.1 to 10 it was one of the scariest
experiences of my life
all right well let's try and get back to
the seriousness it's like all the
suspense is building up and then windows
goes
all right check it out check it out
that's him telling us we shouldn't talk
about this
right right right they're like gates
yeah so there uh floyd's in the store
with this guy maurice lester hall
clerk says that he appears to be under
the influence you can see
maurice lester hall hand him something
maybe he was giving him some change we
don't know what it was sure
there's no reason to assume you know
anything and floyd gets in the vehicle
with him there in this suv
the clerk said he he took this
counterfeit 20
and he at first he was like i'll just
eat i'll eat it because his boss was
like if you take counterfeit money you
got to pay for it
and then he thought about it was like i
can't do that went to his manager and
said what do i do they said call the
cops
when the cop approaches the vehicle you
can see it in the body camera footage
floyd's got something on his tongue we
don't know what it is
the judge said i think i think the judge
said it looked like a tablet it looked
like something was on his tongue and
then it was gone
the defense brings this up so now you
have the circumstance and when i saw
that i was like dude
the toxicology report showed that he had
11 nanograms per milliliter of fentanyl
in a system 5.6 nanograms per
milliliter of norfentanol which is a is
a metaboli
it's a metabolite of fentanyl my
understanding in this context means that
it's the fentanyl that's breaking down
in his body
it could potentially be a precursor
substance that people use so we don't
know for sure but
well uh lydia pulled this up the other
day on the show when when mixing drugs
a lethal dose of fentanyl can be seven
nanograms per milliliter this guy had 11
and 5.6 of north fentanyl can we talk
about this for a second because
i only learned today when lydia picked
me from the airport why people
actually use fentanyl i had been under
the impression this how much of a
straight a jam
that they're getting they're trying to
buy heroin instead of getting heroin
they're getting fentanyl and they're
getting killed i didn't i realized that
people
intentionally take fentanyl and it has
some kind of a purpose can you explain
that a little bit
it's a it's a medication it's an it's an
opioid but so they're
so so it is used like kind of like
percocet or something my understanding
is that
uh yeah it's it's an oh it's a
medication okay and so but
i'll say this outright man just to get
started this story breaks my heart
the story told by the girlfriend is that
she and floyd had
had chronic injury chronic pain and so
they were prescribed
opioids and then like many americans
yeah they became addicted to it prince
so so after their prescriptions cleared
they have a physiological dependence to
this
and then we criminalize the fact that
they're hooked on something their doctor
made them told them to take can we also
explain to people like because i've had
my wisdom teeth maybe other people
haven't i have when you take
like percocet or something like this
they don't understand that it's a
painkiller
but pain is obviously it's not literally
happening in your arm or your mouth it's
happening in your mind
right so what these painkillers do
you're sitting there and it's like
you're on a cloud you're not you're you
know the expression not feeling any pain
it it affects your psychology and your
mood
and you could be sitting just staring at
ian staring at you tim and just feeling
really mellow and relaxed and it's very
easy to see
how this can become hyper addictive
because if you tell someone
all you have to do is you know take this
pill and for hours you're just going to
feel relaxed and happy
and have pure bliss you're not going to
think well the doctor gave it to me
obviously it can't be that dangerous why
wouldn't i and then you get a
physiological dependence and then
because what happens if you stop
you know it's kind of like starting
stopping short in your car i've had a
friend who was a
a heroin heroin addict and your body
starts freaking out because it's not in
a position to make that happy juice or
serotonin whatever it is
and now you're in panic because you're
like if i don't get that feeling back
like it's like fight or flight your
body's it's so it's but it's a very
slippery dangerous slope
it's not just that it's that you level
out like the first time you take it
it feels really good eventually you
normalize and if you stop taking it you
go down
so i had been prescribed percocets uh
several years ago
and they gave me i think they gave me
like 15
or so i took two and then i stopped yeah
it was terrifying
you know why it was the it was the
greatest feeling
and i was like i do not like this man
and that's not like
compared to fentanyl the way is that
right yeah fennel is super conscious yes
yeah wow so that's so so listen listen
here's a dude
who is now in his car he's odd before
he's scared he's going to go to jail the
cops are here
he's like dude i i think it's insane
that we criminalize people who have a
physiological dependence after a doctor
gave him medication
you know trump ran on this ending the
opioid crisis
so now he panics and it it seems based
on the story
he was with his dealer he was buying
drugs cops showed up
he ate them that's what it seems like
here's the other thing about
decriminalization you know obviously i'm
an anarchist and this is my view but but
people don't appreciate when we're
talking about uh decriminalizing drugs
it's the harder drugs that are the most
in need of decriminalization
because those are the most at risk
people who need to have access to
resources who need to not be worried
about being locked in prison with
rapists and murderers
who are the most like when you're in
that state of withdrawal
you're not thinking completely
rationally you're you're your brain's
only thought is
make this feeling your feeling go away
right now and after a while you're
stealing from your family you're
breaking into places you're doing things
you'd never otherwise do
and it's easy to say just go cold turkey
you're if anyone has had writer's block
if anyone's been at the gym you don't
feel like working out imagine that times
a thousand
because your brain is screaming at you
being very articulate
you need to do what you need to do to
get this feeling back so it's
those are the people who need kind of
help and and
also it's very dangerous yeah to put
someone like this in prison
well so if if if you're physiologically
dependent from an addiction to something
like opioids
and you don't get it you can die from
withdrawal
it's it's it's brutal shocking pain and
so look he was driving i get it i get it
man you break the law you break the law
sure
right and so i think what we need to do
is we need to reform the system the
problem i have with this is now
it's looking to me like like chauvin's
going to get acquitted
and it's also looking like he should be
but it's also looking like the state
is responsible for all of it the problem
here is that the state
is prosecuting chauvin as a scapegoat
for their broken system with the with
the war on drugs
and for their broken policies where they
train the police to do this maneuver
with the knee
so if you got a problem with the knee on
the neck i hear you i hear you
it was the police that told him to do it
if you got a problem with chauvin
with with floyd getting arrested i agree
man it's the war on drugs
imagine if someone if someone walked up
and they and imagine if it wasn't a
criminal act
to be to be addicted or to be dry any
substance buying these substances or at
the very least you knew
the penalty was a light stint in rehab
or a clinic
floyd would not have panicked the way he
would the the the chaos was not would
not have been sued
i get it there's a 20 bill i can't
believe someone lost their life over 20
let's talk a little further uh all
mountain all money is counterfeit
there we go there's no reason for this
20 bill it used to be backed by gold
meaning i can go to a store
or whatever the bank and say i want 20
worth of gold instead of this bill
fdr uh when he became president broke
every contract in america unilaterally
because the contract said
tim you're going to paint my house for
500 or gold equivalent right
uh and if it was super inflation i'm
like you know what i don't want the 500
give me the gold
fdr said all those clauses are illegal
not only did he do that
he made it illegal for anyone to own
gold right so they really made sure that
gold couldn't be used as a base of
currency
and only now let me just finish my
thought only now thanks to things like
ethereum
crypto bitcoin are there ways for people
to store money
it's it's not the same as gold obviously
but these are a better store
than politicians who could print at will
and if everyone listened to me and
bought ethereum when i was in the show
and said to buy it they would have been
up like two and a half times the money
through all the time
yeah yesterday so the glasses aren't
just for show
dapper so look back back to george floyd
i just my view is i wish our criminal
justice system
was rehabilitative and not retribution
or just punitive like okay we're mad you
did this so put them in a box
let's can we talk about this else i
don't interrupt you a lot of times
conservatives are like the guy
point out correctly point correctly this
guy pointed a gun at a pregnant woman
during an armed robbery it's like well
if that's the case then he shouldn't be
on the street either
so no matter which way you cut it this
is a screwed up situation
what you mean floyd did yeah previously
yeah if someone is this much of a
violent criminal
then they shouldn't they should at least
be like we have a sex offenders registry
why is there not some kind of violent
criminal offenders register when
someone's doing something that egregious
yeah maybe excite we're talking about
gun control and i said if you pay your
debt to society you get your gun back
you get your vote back
and so a lot of people said yeah but if
you're violent and i'm like well then if
this
if you've listen so you're talking about
an extended sentence
this is not okay by all means sure argue
that i'm saying literally if they're
like
you did this so your punishment is five
years five years later you get out
congratulations here's your gun here's
your voter registration id card whatever
you need right well they don't do voter
id but you get the point right
so uh maybe there would be a list or so
i'm still not
necessarily a big fan but i understand
the idea and ultimately what i'm saying
is
the listen the most violent president
the most violent criminals are always
the presidents in the senate
because they're the ones who declare war
look how much blood is on their hands
the state is at fault yes right they pay
and hold on but they're the ones
prosecuting right now
imagine realizing this when the leftist
chant
the whole damn system is guilty as hell
i'm like right here with you
we got a problem here the war on drugs
doesn't work it's never worked it's
creating criminals out of victims
it's great like look i understand this
violent crime i was i was tweeting up a
storm
during trump saying trump should should
pardon every non-violent drug offender
with some review because some might
plead down but the general idea is
if you were a non-violent drug offender
that's the only thing you did get him
out of there
get him some help have someone give a
talking to and like help them work
through their withdrawals and their
addictions
that's what i was all about so the
system is putting these people in prison
making them hardened criminals making so
they can't vote i think the system is
broken
now the problem is they're demanding the
state that is at fault put chauvin on
trial an individual officer
working working as an individual for the
state who is told to do something by the
state i have a problem with that
if we as a community say we need people
to be working on behalf of the state to
enforce the law
and then the individual says i'm willing
to do that and then we say okay but you
have no
legal protections in the event that we
we actually end up saying we don't like
what the state is doing
change the state itself but don't as a
community ask someone to do something
and then get mad when they do it you see
what i'm saying yeah i just don't agree
i know you're an anarchist yeah my point
is like
most people seem to like the police i
know your opinion and we'll definitely
talk about it because i think it's it's
fascinating i don't think that
that that's factual that most people
like the police i think it's very
dependent on your
uh environment also the idea of the
police and the individual police is a
different thing too
yes just like everyone hates politicians
but they like their congressmen
yeah yeah so so maybe look where i was
in
in chicago nobody liked cops where i was
can i ask you were they wrong were they
are the cops in chicago
the kind decent normal people or are
they
okay there's my answer no but you know
what i'm saying like when you people the
reputation
of the police in chicago but let me
clarify i had been saved from a mugging
by cops
where they literally grabbed the mugger
and slammed them against the wall and
you were only mugged because you're
unarmed because of the police
yeah you were that mugging was pause
actually we did it so so we did a bonus
segment yesterday with jack murphy are
we allowed to show that
i don't know okay but whatever so so
yeah i uh
yeah i guess you could call it that no
but my point is you you you exerci you
you're
you're outspoken about ex not outspoken
just you you exercise your second
amendment rights
the other day on the bonus segment you
guys are going to want to watch this if
you want to see me screaming at the top
of my lungs
this is one of the best we've ever done
i was basically saying the problem with
chicago
is that they banned guns and so long
story short
jack said about this incident in dc
where this guy gets carjacked yeah the
car flips over and he dies
he should have just given the car up and
i said no he should not have just given
his car up and jack made a good point
you know
don't you think his kids would prefer it
if he lived if he just gave that car
away
and i said if every single person looked
dead in the eyes the criminal attempting
to harass or press them and said i will
blow your head off
if you go near me this would stop the
problem is
in chicago for instance they make it
illegal to own guns and so what happens
then
is the criminals know you can't do
anything and they can point a gun at you
and and then the cops tell you they tell
you this you know what you do the
officers say
just make sure you comply with
everything they want you know what i
said
no so when the guy tried mugging me i
laughed i just kept walking
and i i was i just basically ignored him
i was like dude first of all i'm broke i
don't have any money
and he threatened me with a knife and i
just laughed i'm like i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna do anything
the point is if people had the right to
defend themselves
and someone walked up to you and said
give me your stuff you'd be like oh i
got something for you it's called the
45.
instead but there is tactical retreat in
the art of war you don't want to let
someone goad you in the comments
escalate yeah that's very much to rey
who's great i don't know if you've had
him on the show yeah definitely
matter shout out to much um he does
workshops where he talks about
de-escalation
and i think this is something that is
very important and i'm saying this is
someone born in the soviet union
it's very important for people
especially young males especially
low status young males to be educated
and be told you know what if you take a
step back you're not a coward
you're not a woman you're not whatever
pejorative you want to use sometimes
it's okay to be like you know what
fine i'm not gonna this is not gonna
escalate because
uh um jeannette rankin who was the only
member of congress to vote against world
war one in world war
ii she said you don't win a war any more
than you win a hurricane
but it's kind of like a knife or a
gunfight it's going to end ugly at the
very least even in a free society
you're going to have to sit down and
adjudicate and say i drew this gun in
this person for this reason
i'm not a threat i don't shouldn't have
my uh gun rights revoked
so i'm not talking about a fight over
honor
which is a lot of what happens in
chicago where two guys refuse to back
down because of their honor
no no no no no no don't die for pride
you know what i mean i'm talking about
your
you know a guy you got a couple kids and
you're with your wife and the state says
you can't have guns anymore
and you know you live in chiraq so you
know a lot of people in chicago do
they go and illegally buy them anyway of
course and there's a lot of good you
know hard-working families
with no criminal history who are who are
in felony possession of firearms because
they refuse to be victims to these gangs
who terrorize their neighborhoods and
who's enforcing these laws
the state and the police okay so what do
you think should be done
when someone takes an oath to uphold the
constitution
and in violating that oaf they leave
poor helpless people defenseless in
their homes do you think these people
should be respected
no okay my work here is done
i'm out of here but we agree i think
there needs to be heavy reform
and the problem is social enforcement
yes the fact that the police
will face no repercussions for this so
it used to be the cop would show up and
they'd get a free hot dog
now we're hearing a lot that they don't
but the problem is it's not for the
right reason so bringing it back to
shove and my point is this
if the left said i don't care about
chauvin
i care about the police department i
care about the laws
the war on drugs doesn't work people who
should not be criminals are being
criminalized
unfortunately there's there's there's
big gaps in the logical consistency of
many many people and i assure you i
recognize this i have it as well same as
you all do yes of course but when you
have people who say
there was something posted by um rachel
maddow
it was it said people who would take the
rights from others deserve
none themselves or whatever and so i
tweeted rachel meadow agree rachel
maddow agrees
all gun control should be abolished yeah
because
what she doesn't understand is that she
regularly advocates for taking people's
rights away she understands
sure sure so these the a lot of these
people on the left
many of the progressives they're
actually pro-gun they absolutely are
like the socialist rifle association
types and then there's a decent overlap
with many of these antifa people
some of these anti-foot people recently
arrested in portland were armed with
guns well
the mar the the marxists are very
pro-gun because the argument
you know i'm writing about this my
upcoming book the white pill
the first there's a myth among the
boomer conservatives that gun control
started as a result
of they didn't want like uh black people
to become armed um
post-civil war it actually started in
illinois
because a lot of these labor unions were
forming militias
and they were drilling because they were
ready to start a revolution
and this was a big problem it's like
wait a minute the second amendment
specifically says you should have a
militia
they're forming labor militias in the
idea of eventually killing the
capitalists and taking over
and this was a huge supreme court case
and they lost and that's where gun
control really kind of started what year
was it
i think 1870 so so and then and then
what within like a couple decades what
was it called the haymarket massacre was
that what it was
that you're don't spoil my book but yes
hey market massacre that's in chicago
was that in chicago that is in chicago
yes
yeah that was what happened without
someone through dynamite or something
okay so okay this is
this is the story of lewis link who's on
the cover of the anarchist handbook
which i'll be back on
uh to talk about when it's ready
assuming i don't burn this bridge today
um who knows it's a live show let's
start with
so everybody understands the context
you're saying that gun control starts
with these labor unions
and now we're talking about the hey mars
hey market massacre it's a very
very quick transition so what happens is
in illinois you have these
they're very heavily immigrant very
heavily german uh labor unions are
forming militias and they're they're
they're mustering i think it's the term
when they're you know you're practicing
so on and so forth
there was a union meeting in haymarket
square in chicago which is
still around and different people were
talking
uh at night a bomb got thrown dynamite
a lot of people got killed including
several police officers a bunch of
anarchists
were rounded up some of whom were not
even there
and they were accused of conspiracy to
commit murder because they were
advocating these radical ideas
one of them was someone named lewis ling
if you look him up on
the internet he looks like channing
tatum it looks like a contemporary photo
even though from 1870 something it's
crazy
what is it louis lange ling l-i-n-g-g
he's the stud of anarchism he was the
first che guevara
basically i'm not kidding i'm not right
i'm impressed yeah he's a hunk
so they put these anarchists on trial
lewis sling they had searched his house
and there was a lot of dynamite in his
house
and his lawyer said weekly well he's got
to write dynamite in his house
this has become a meme where lewis ling
is alleged to have said i couldn't have
thrown that bomb
i was at home making bombs because he
wasn't there
but a bomb got thrown they were
sentenced to death
they were all hanged louis was one of
the four of them were excuse me
or five lewis escaped the hanging
because he snuck in a blasting cap into
his jail cell
blew off his jaw and then wrote in blood
on the wall
hooray for anarchy the others one of
them when he
was being hanged said someday the voices
you strangle
uh will uh be louder than the someday
the
i forget the term whatever there's a
they got pardoned many years later and
there's a memorial to them right now in
chicago
but this is where a lot of it started
the gun control stuff yes
wow well we so the conservatives it's
funny the aclu
also got started defending communists uh
because it was
this radical revolutionary idea so a lot
of conservatives like like
to adopt these ideas and they don't
realize where their origins are
from the radical radical left so this
could have been a false flag like
the legal the law could have thrown
dynamite in and blame that's what they
said
they said this was this is an agent
provocateur paid for by the capitalists
to get us in trouble and we still don't
know who threw the bomb to this day so
let's wrap this back
to uh the origin of how we start talking
about this which was uh
the chauvin trial they're they're going
after one guy
derek chovin if they convict him the
state
which in my opinion is responsible will
cheer and hurrah
and all of the activists will be
satisfied well probably not but
if the idea is they want chauvin put on
trial as the individual
they're ignoring what's really going on
and i liken this
to you know i'll put it exactly like
this it's like imagine if
there was a you know in fetal japan the
ninja was tasked with taking out the
emperor instead he fought with
the palace guard and then celebrated
when the palace guard one of them
you know was removed from his post
chauvin is just one guy who works for a
system
getting that guy convicted won't change
anything and he was just some guy
who was doing like you know he was told
here's how you restrain someone now
whether or not he actually did anything
wrong in that capacity
stopping floyd i disagree with the war
on drugs but there's arguments about
what you do when there's
when there's statutory law in the books
derek chauvin
was trained by the minneapolis police to
do it's called
the recovery position that's what it
said in the training thing that they
released
because if you put your knee on their
back they could asphyxiate so he
literally moves his knee
should this guy be convicted after
everything we've seen with all the
evidence
chauvin with the fentanyl in his system
with a guy who now it appears to be a
dealer
you know he appeared to be high floyd
said before he was even restrained did
you see this i can't breathe he said it
before he was even restrained
so all of that leads to the conclusion
of at least bare minimum reasonable
doubt
my problem the war on drugs first and
foremost is a big part of this
especially when i saw you know floyd's
girlfriend testify about
opioid addiction and what they were
going through and i was like this is
insane man
that we're doing this the problem i have
is the activists who are angry
are being easily distracted and pointing
at one guy and when he's convicted
nothing will change they will not do
anything there's two things one they
want to make an example of him to make
all the other cops
online two is i just want to point out
what the slog the thing on the
memorial is because it's a great quote
he said um this is august
who's one of the ones who was hanged he
says the day will come when our silence
will be more powerful than the voice you
were strangling today
so i think that's the case with a lot of
people who are killed by the state it's
that they are silenced
but you know what they represent which
might not actually be accurate
you know speaks speaks volumes yeah well
michael the state realized that and so
now they go for character assassination
instead sure
they they learned they learned a while
back and i'm surprised it took him as
long as it did to be honest
when they were like hey if we got a
problem we just kill him and it's like
well congratulations you've made a
martyr who's immortal now
right so they have to smear your
reputation and make you a nasty diddler
or something and then all of a sudden
your legacy is destroyed and nobody
wants to reference your name anymore
and they're trying to do that with the
trump administration there were several
articles
written how they're trying to make
people trying to make anyone who worked
for him
radioactive and unhirable remember it
was tough for the former president
to i mean your job as defense attorneys
to defend child abu
users you know murderers rapists like
the most horrible people that's your job
they were having trouble finding
people to defend the sitting the the
sitting or at the time former president
uh for the impeachment trial and now you
see what facebook
said right now the voice of the
president is not allowed on their
platform
i saw that yeah the voice of larry trump
yeah what was that lara trump the
president's uh
uh daughter-in-law um she interviewed
him
he didn't say anything particularly
inflammatory didn't talk about the
election
they pulled the video and they said you
cannot have
trump's voice on our site so they have
ai
just clocking trump's voice ready to
pull up no they knew no apparently
yeah when she expressed her intention
they didn't call her
yeah and they sent an email saying like
just so you know if you do this
you're gone and then she was like i'm
gonna do it anyway and i was like right
on they're
trying to vanish a president from
existence who's still alive
this is let me ask you do you think
that the moves being made by the
establishment today are something new
or do you think those individuals in
this power structure has always existed
but slipped up
i i think they're losing their power i
think these are the same moves
um they're trying to make people making
people radioactive has happened
for a very long time uh in this country
and i think they have to ramp it up
because if there's three networks abc
cbs nbc
the three of us can get in a room and be
like look this guy's a clown
we're not going to repeat him yes yes
yes shake hands that's why a lot of
ideas that were kind of on the fringe
would be heard by the mainstream because
it's like the three of them said yeah
we're not going to talk about it
now when you have this show and infinite
shows on youtube on
or on rumble and all these other other
locations it's impossible to have a
monopoly of the megaphone
so now they're freaking out because it's
very difficult to sustain
a regime based on mistruths or untruths
when all it takes is one jerk with a
twitter account to be like
uh this isn't accurate and then your
whole facade falls like finding out your
wife has been cheating on you
maybe she cheated on you once but that
changes the whole 10 years
the crazy thing about it is you know
what we're seeing with the censorship or
seeing with stephen crowder
it's it's clearly insane and it's it's
like every single time a new story
happens it's worse than it's been why do
you say what do you mean by insane
because when
when i when i i heard about this when i
was doing my north korea book a lot of
times people say insane when they just
don't understand
the system and a lot of times the system
is coherent i mean insane as in in the
figurative that
it's so shockingly outrageous it would
make
anyone think the world is you know gone
nuts or
i just mean insane as in like is a
hyperbolic this is okay
what is going on this is this is dialed
up to 11. yeah yeah
crowder broke no rule he did not break a
single rule i know because i've spoken
with google on the phone with google
representatives on the phone
about their rules it's really
interesting i wonder if crowder will sue
them for defamation
because what they're telling people is
that
in these articles where people ask about
crowder they say that he violated
their deceptive policy or spam policy
but the specific email that got sent out
by google said you can't do this
particular thing
crowder did not do that particular thing
he said you can't say these two things
the same time crowder did not say those
two things
but then they tell the press he violated
that rule
well that's a false statement of fact he
didn't they claimed he
they removed a video for trying to uh
you know circumvent his restriction he
didn't the rules clearly state
or at least google has said you can
upload to another channel if the content
is substantially different
which it was he filmed a cell phone
video saying hey guys here's what's
happening it wasn't his normal show
too bad they said so this is this is
crazy right
now here's the thing even if they get
rid of crowder and it really does feel
like as time goes on they're they are
strangling these networks but can i
interrupt because there's there's all
these names that we
that they've successfully picked off one
by one that we forget about
remember nick monroe yes yes absolutely
i remember he was
he i mean he was a badass on twitter who
is he he was a twitter journalist shout
out to nick if he's watching
and he would be breaking a lot of
stories because there would be something
in the corporate press
and he would just he was this nerdy kid
with the computer and a lot of spare
time
and he'd do his due diligence and he'd
find articles like
what you're saying is is not accurate
here's the receipts
they got rid of him carpe dunked him who
was president trump's meme maker
this guy is basically making memes for
the president and things they're going
viral
they yanked him shout out to my friend
carpenter so there and there's others
that we can name that thing
milo was a shocking one to me that was
like i don't know that was the shocking
to me
not shocking he put in his twitter
profile that he worked for buzzfeed it
was that they banned him across
all the platforms that was the shock the
collusion yes right the fact that when
it comes to these higher profile
personalities
uh none of them should be banned by the
way i just don't think so um
they colluded or at the very least they
were like waiting for the moment when
they could all act in concert and for
some reason did
although it's not completely unified
because like twitter waits a day or two
before they finally do it well they
waited a while for alex jones
right yeah that's another one but that
that collusion but it it's very but the
thing is like i'll play devil's advocate
to some extent
i don't think people appreciate how weak
a lot of corporate america is
and no one wants to stick out their neck
so it's a lot easier for me
as jack dorsey if youtube and zuckerberg
are all doing this
for me to be like there's no cost for me
to join them but if i'm sticking my neck
out like we saw with black lives matter
and the guy who ran crossfit
and he's like this has nothing to do
with us we're we're you know gay
exercise organization they're like well
you know now you're the odd one out yeah
so very much group thing does play into
this is
not necessarily nefarious uh well here's
what i wonder
obviously there is a mainstream and
youtube will will pick off one by one
all these big channels and they're
really homogenizing everything i don't
know how long will last a lot of people
are like dude we'll never get banned you
do milk toast even though facebook
already removed me
nick monroe is i mean i'm not gonna call
you milk toast nicki monroe was not some
kind of radical
yeah they said it was circumvention yeah
but so
even after they do that the the
technology
cryptocurrency your own private websites
open source text still exists
crowder has a website he has mug club
he's got uh uh you know he's with blaze
tv
they can reduce a decent amount of his
reach on their platforms
but in the end look at what happens when
trump gets gets banned off uh
twitter people start losing followers
like crazy right
a lot of people were only on twitter for
the president in the first place
when patreon banned carl benjamin who
now runs the lotus eaters podcast which
you guys should check out
i lost a ton of support from people who
are messaging me saying dude
love your work but i'm here for a lot of
people and i have to move now because
you know my like
my favorite show is you know carl's show
so i'm getting off of patreon
and then i had no choice if i stayed on
i would have lost twenty or twenty five
percent
you went through that personally i
didn't know you weren't patreon i went
through
dave rubin launched locals now i'm on
malista.locals.com it's a patreon
facebook hybrid people can
it's free to join five bucks if you want
to contribute the point
look i know you're not a fan whatever
the point is i got off patreon the
second
i could there was an alternative because
it's not a sustainable
career as a creative type to know that
overnight
i could have all my work vanished
without any recourse without any
explanation whereas now
i can call reuben up and be like yo
what's going on and have an actual
response i think that's a very big
difference
and a lot of people have the ability to
call jack conte of patreon do the same
thing
okay i did not have that ability right
right so so right now
the issue i take and look i i think
dave's great i think he's a friend
uh um and local sounds awesome my issue
is and always
will be centralizing
basically joining any of these platforms
means
they could remove me whenever they want
and what do you think is going to happen
and and i mean wouldn't be who they
who's
you mean locals or me personally right
right right now it's dave rubin he can
snap his fingers and destroy your career
i i don't know about that or like um i
mean your income
your stream everything you've posted on
locals but i mean and i'd be a little
hyperbolic with a career
you've got other platforms and he could
be i thought you meant being hyperbolic
about they did you have a career
[Laughter]
fair a little bear i am here fair there
um but i i mean that's that's a function
of anything if you're going to be a
waiter if you're going to be a chef
i mean you're going to have some owner
someone's going to unless you're totally
sure employed
so reduce that amount sure you're
singing my song
that's why we started timcast.com i was
like why should i be on someone else's
platform i should make my own
and what my plan is now we've talked
about it quite a bit ian's recommended
some some developers you might have
we're going to make an open source
plugin that anyone could just drop on
their own website which creates the full
package subscription model
and i have no control over it that's a
great that's a great idea absolutely
that's it
this is this i am going to with this
project
attempt i will say to destroy all of
these subscription services every single
one of those just
add more power to you i think what this
is something that i
i get into a lot on twitter people are
so
cause they sarcastically say oh just
build your own patreon just build your
own website
it's like there's a lot of smart people
who are seeing these problems coming
down the road
it's hard to miss these problems are
godzilla sized and
all it's going to take is one smart
person here you go
and be like this is going to be a
workaround and once this problem is
solved it is solved
permanently i'm old enough i'm 63
to remember when the idea i'm old enough
to remember
when people said the idea of oh make
your own website would have been an
absurdity
now it takes 10 minutes 10 minutes yeah
you get a wordpress plugin yeah and
they're amazing so
we want to start i mean look you don't
need a lot for your own subscription
service like timcast.com is not this
it's
it's not the biggest thing in the world
it's it's a relatively simple wordpress
from the new members we got we were able
to make a better website launching soon
which is now pro and from those members
we're not gonna start funding
tv shows movies and i actually i read
through a treatment for a show
we might produce this is amazing stuff
it's gonna be awesome
i want to create an open source project
that someone could just install on a web
server like
they find a hosting company they install
it boom when you go to their website
it looks like any of these subscription
services it's got a login signup
function it's got a database
now there's some things you have to be
responsible for security things like
that
your own payment processors like that
will probably be striper paypal like
most people use
but it'll be like one click boom package
upload your website exists
then you'll have all the wordpress
functioning for for uploading photos and
you'll have you have a little bit of a
learning curve but for the most part you
will have
a totally decentralized patreon system
let me let me let me tell you
i talked to jack conti of of patreon a
couple times
when uh people got banned and just to
for a lot of people who may you know not
understand what's going on patreon is a
subscription service
they abruptly banned lauren southern
eliminating her income they later
abruptly banned carl benjamin
eliminating his income
and let's uh just to people understand
abruptly means it's not like youtube
where you get a strike it's like you
wake up and
all your names are gone all your money's
gone any money that they hadn't escorted
they pulled for you you're not seeing a
penny of this
this is very sudden and it's out of
nowhere and you're not given warnings
this is
it's people need to appreciate how
extreme this is so lauren southern got
pulled
overnight without warning wakes up one
day to find out her income stream is
just gone
then they said don't worry we'll never
do it again and then they did it again
to carl benjamin
what i was told long story short in a pr
in a phone call with jack and i talked
to him for a long time on
a couple different occasions i'll give
you the gist of it without telling you
necessarily specifics but i'll respect
his privacy in that regard but it's
simple the sentiment was this
when one of our partners comes to us and
says we're going to shut down your
entire website
unless you get rid of one person i have
a choice to make yeah ten thousand
people's careers and those livelihoods
or one well the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few my
response was
tell them to shove off and then when
those ten thousand people and all their
10
000 followers or 1 million followers
each are wondering what happened
i'll point them in your direction
instead they they just give up
so i'll tell you this much as i respect
dave rubin what do you think would
happen
if mastercard called him up like like
like they did to patreon and they say if
you don't get rid of malice we shut your
company down overnight
well let's just pretend he's saying
bridge of fedex because she's much more
expendable with me love you
love you we don't have to we don't have
to argue about this because this
actually happened
so cody wilson who is awesome who's the
guy behind ghost guns yes uh defense
distributed
wearing the shirt right now um he had
something called hatreon
and he was trying to make a patreon
alternative where people who are banned
from patreon can go there and patreon
people who are heretics yeah and his
issue why he had to shut it down
is because precise like you said visa or
strike one of the payment process
says no we're not doing business with
you if you can't get money from person
eight for
person b it's really not over the
internet there's nothing because we
change
everyone's flipping out like malice
you're ignoring this how's the market to
solve from this i'm telling people right
now
whether it's through crypto or some
other mechanism there are a lot of smart
people
who are who see this for the problem
that it is and are taking steps to
work around this and this is something
that absolutely has to happen
but i'm sure you know even better than i
do people who are doing this and trying
to have the work around so that visa
doesn't have that kind of you by the
throat and the big problem
it's very simple every single person
that i talk to
about this not every single person
there's there's a few you know we we
have pocket that they sponsor us they
want to go full decentralized blockchain
so they're they're that
we're glad to have them sponsor the show
you know when we have when we do when we
do their shout outs periodically
um but and it seems like they're truly
decentralized like it's all on you it's
you're the note operator it's yours and
that sounds
like a good place to start but a lot of
these companies
need to make money yeah how do they fund
the development and so i have people
saying to me
like you know when i was pitching this
idea of creating an open source
decentralized plug-in that other
you run it yourself don't look at me i
got nothing to do with it i can't ban
you it's not my website
and they're like yeah well how do you
fund that like are you going to charge
them a percentage fee is like no
we give it away for free because we're
socialists here at tim cast irl
to a certain degree uh yes i absolutely
am going to take
the money that that you know some of the
excess money we get
and create a system that will protect
free speech
and subscription services for many other
people now it may be that you know
ian downloads this package and he
creates his own website
and then his payment processor bans him
but that won't affect anybody else and
there's nothing we can do about that's
between him and his business
we don't need that centralized node
individual who has that power we take
that power away
i think the ultimate value here for my
company and everyone else's is it
protects
us in the long run if everyone is on a
decentralized system now here's the best
part
just one more thing it's also good for
your company because good karma
gives you dividends i i'm a firm
believer if you help people and empower
them it comes back to you in the future
but here's here's the other way it's
going to really help us i guess you
don't care i do i do
i want to make a program those people
spin up their own crypto yeah check it
out
with this plugin it will create a
network between everyone who uses it
so we're very preliminary ian so far
mentioned a few rss3 we basically want
to evolve rss so you can
now have yours use gabs to center
browser i've not it's like a browser you
download like chrome or whatever but you
go to a website and then you can comment
on the website
on the browser so something like that
with like a matrix login
passport where you have your name and
all your data of like who you're
subscribed to
you can put your payments through that
um and you check
rss i'm just very excited to be here
learning about how skynet was built
yes software code we'll be able to watch
the ai go haywire and see why it did in
real time
i'll tell you my my vision would be if i
upload this this package to my server
and press install or whatever and get
this template
it's going to have you know videos blogs
login you log in
then then like i on the back end have to
put in my my bank and all the stuff and
set that up
but there will also be a networking link
that when you go to it
it shows you trending websites so if ian
has ian crossland.net
running the same thing and he got a
million views this week
in that networking it'll be like here's
one of the biggest shows and we can't
control that it's just an open source
network protocol that tracks big
channels it could eventually create a
more power you have the more power you
gain kind of thing but ultimately no one
will be
who has ian crossland.com i don't this
guy ian crossland
he's like a boy scout or something is
that right like literally a kid
well he's a guy okay older man uh cool
dude i think i've only seen him from a
distance you know the head of the cia
former head of the cia
john o'brennan yeah someone should look
at jonobrennen.com
that the website is going down right now
no no i think ten thousand people
mentioned this one before yeah
is it good yeah it's good also cadbury
creme eggs.com oh gosh
i own it oh you do yeah i love this
easter on sunday
it's it's easter every day michael
i was going to say about all right
that's because they keep writing what's
in the grave
well let's uh uh let's let's get very
serious with the censorship stuff and
why i think it's so important so
look i'm talking a lot i don't like
talking a lot when it comes to projects
we have not done
okay right sure so yeah
i'll tell you that as far as we've come
with this is we've speculated on some
ideas and ian's been like i've got a
handful of developers who can maybe get
started on the project
people keep messaging me too and
continue to do that please uh twitter's
a good place
i'm thinking maybe we need to start a
501c3 i think it's about time in
delaware and and that's
well i don't know where but so 501c3
whose mission is to
create this open source subscription
networking service
so that people control their own patreon
i'll tell you why right now
as we are seeing youtube ban donald
trump's voice
yeah the result of this is unprecedented
is it youtube also or just instagram i'm
sorry i'm sorry okay i just i really
want to make sure we get that right yeah
yeah as we're
as we are seeing facebook and instagram
banned the voice of the president but
youtube did take down right side
broadcasting networks video of trump's
giving us trump being a speech
all of these moves in big tech
censorship is leading to
a it's it's building up power for the
establishment they're trying to regain
control
you know earlier of course you mentioned
it used to be three networks it's really
easy for them to control everything now
it's harder
what ends up happening is i'm gonna i
think it's impossible but go ahead
right what ends up happening is once
they start centralizing control by
having their allies in tech ban people
will they win elections donald trump
loses and then the result of this
is terrifying the new york post reports
u.s expresses unwavering support for
ukraine amid russian military movements
the new york times reports fighting
escalates in eastern ukraine signaling
the end to another ceasefire ukraine and
russia issued statements tuesday noting
the worsening of a conflict that has
been on a low simmer for years with
countless ceasefires
it's it's picking up and what's
fascinating about this is that
before donald trump this was a major
move
by the existing u.s establishment
intelligence agencies the military
industrial complex
gaining control getting western
influence into ukraine yeah
cr and then creating this major conflict
don't get me wrong putin has a lot
to to account for in terms of his
responsibility here the seizing of
crimea
and the the the assistance he's
providing to the separatists in the east
but this is the big war this is or i
should say this is one of the big
conflicts
having a lot to do with the gazprom
natural gas monopoly
europe is faced with very high energy
prices they wanted to get a pipeline
from it's called the cutter turkey
pipeline
long story short all of these pieces
come together in really interesting ways
in 2009 as a report by the guardian the
us wanted to destabilize syria
because syria was refusing u.s interests
refusing that to allow them to build a
pipeline
that would bring natural gas into europe
well syria said
outright russia is our ally and we will
not harm their business interests with
their gas monopoly
convenient for us there was a civil war
revolution and conflict and attempts to
destabilize syria
occurred and u.s interests are there
even right now reports that the u.s is
moving more in
so it's unsurprising to me that we're a
couple months out of joe biden becoming
president and all of a sudden ukraine
lights back
up i mean of course it's not surprising
i mean
i think anyone who's even remotely
red-pilled understands perfectly well
there's these international networks
where they work together and joe biden
was their guy
and here's the here's what really
bothers me about joe biden this is i
think the worst thing you can say about
him and it's something that's not even
really particularly controversial
if you in my opinion correctly regarded
the iraq war as a mistake right let's
suppose i was a chef i've used this
metaphor before
and i accidentally undercook some
chicken and someone dies right like god
forbid
as not only would i feel enormous guilt
i'm like okay
i need to take mechanisms if i'm gonna
still remain a chef which i know that i
would do because i killed someone god
forbid
uh i'm gonna take steps to make sure
this kind of thing never happens again
because this is so beyond the pale and
inappropriate i don't know how many
people die in the iraq war
iraqis and americans alike if joe biden
says this was a mistake and you feel
guilt over
tens of thousands hundred thousands of
innocent lives being hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of
instant lives or maybe not even innocent
lives but i don't think people
everyone should be killed i would be
like all right i'm going to make sure
this doesn't happen again i'm going to
staff
my white house with people who don't
think this way i'm going to make
steps to kind of put fail safes in place
that i mean the the the urine in his
depends wasn't dry
before he was sending arms to syria yeah
this is
very disturbing and i gotta tell you i i
i
you you see these photos of these
hippies in the 60s with the soldiers
and this girl hippie puts the daisy in
the in the the in the barrel of girl
hippie that's a very famous photo yeah
and as a kid i thought
what an idiot and now i think you know
what she's not the idiot
because she's really even though she's
maybe not even not particularly
uh whatever sophisticated her thoughts
she's like you know what this is wrong
and and we're all raised to think that
war is a last resort
but it's treated as a first priority by
the state and this is one of the biggest
reasons i'm an anarchist
war is so glorified and even when it
happens like everyone's just like uh
and i'm like do you understand what this
means bombs from the sky
and children and it's the truth is they
don't understand
yeah they haven't experienced you know
yeah yeah you're right i don't even
understand it because right
you know what it is to me the united
states is the capital city in the hunger
games
where they're all totally oblivious to
the suffering of the outside districts
who are being beaten and forced to fight
to the death
and they're like so what and they're
drinking epic to vomit and keep eating
until the war comes to them you see it
was i believe it was the cia that
referred to
uh um i'll keep the language light okay
um the cia said actions in the middle
east resulted in blowback yeah
that when we were going over there
meddling in governments
arming rebel groups people got mad at us
over there
and they brought it back over here and
all of a sudden the people in the
capital are shocked what's happening why
is it happening don't worry
they just hit you for your freedoms yeah
some simple answer
so you get these people blindly and uh
ignorantly just cheering and dancing for
the war machine
and then when it comes back to them they
they patch you on that and say oh it's
because of your freedoms don't worry
not realizing that dude maybe if we just
minded our own business a little bit
and worked on ourselves people wouldn't
be doing these things
now there are some serious challenges
though china's expansion into many of
these areas their authoritarianism
they're trying to take over and it seems
like they're doing a heck of a good job
of it which is scary to me
because if they end up as the global
power i don't like the idea of them
gaining influence over us but it seems
like it's happening
happening either way but the thing is
they're not gaining influence over us
through militarily
right they're gaining influence of
religious the same way the soviet union
did through surreptitious means through
intelligence uh and through journalism
and thing and getting the right people
uh who are kind of um fans of theirs to
some extent or at least neutral
in the right positions of power that's
the insidious part it's not
china is not going to fight the us maybe
through a proxy war like the korean war
where it's not going to be like a world
war iii god forbid
but they are going to do mechanisms to
make sure that their opinions
are presented as um unarguable with in
the states
shout out to the fourth turning which
you're familiar with i believe yes i'm
not
stross how generational theory no so
this is book uh
about 25 years ago they just look a
little bit shocked i'm shook
yeah i'm surprised that michael hadn't
heard of that every every 20 years is a
new season and every 80 years we go
through a major upheaval
oh god i hate stuff like this it is oh
my god
i don't like it this is like astrology
sure interesting what uh 80 years ago
we had world war ii eight years before
that we had a civil war eight years
before that we had a revolutionary okay
and look
every president who was inaugurated um
it was
1789 1865 1933 and would have been 2005.
where is that 72 years in between
it was washington lincoln fdr so it
would have been george bush's second
term
so yes sometimes these patterns appear
but to claim that they're
kind of inevitable i i really rejected i
don't think they're inevitable
but if the implication is that these
cycles tend to repeat i think this is
the kind of thing where you get the
conclusion you force the data to fit it
well
perhaps they wrote this book 20 years
ago and they did predict
a certain amount of things and certain
amount of things they got wrong because
that's typically the case when someone's
speculating
but the general idea is it's actually
really simple to explain
strong men make good times good men i'm
sorry strong men make good times good
times make weak men
weak men make hard times hard times make
strong men have you heard that before
i have the general idea is that we've
seen it with generational wealth it
typically lasts three generations
the individual who came from nothing and
worked really hard and understood what
gumption was
starts a business makes a lot of money
sure then they have a kid the kid grows
up yeah sure sleeps the shirt sleeves in
three generations yeah right
and so that's kind of the general idea
that we we're now entering this period
where you have a bunch of
very entitled people who simultaneously
complain about the police but then
demand that the state be given more
power over many other aspects of their
lives there's a lack of logic and a lot
of what their
you know decision making is i digress
the point is
according to this book we are entering
the winter period which should end with
some kind of calamity but here's the
issue
the problem is that people tend to they
they it's not always incorrect
they base the future off of the past we
should look to the past to try and
understand what will happen in the
future
but there's many things you can't
predict because of a change in
methodology and technologies
yes to clarify as many people think
strassa generational theory is
predicting a massive world war with
china
strassau generational theory says that
each war is fought with the most
powerful weapons of the time
the question we rose on the show is and
that might be social media no it's love
i think it's lasers yes care bear stare
is the most powerful weapon you know
what i mean
a lot of people assume it's nuclear
weapons because world war ii
sure it's been 80 years yeah the mind
control
social media manipulation and propaganda
is infinitely more powerful right now
you can take over a country without
firing a single bullet you can convince
the people to cheer for you
as you storm their beaches i i disagree
because uh
when what's his name um uh he uh he
wrote the book propaganda
and there's uh um this is in the future
there's bernays book and then there's
walter littman's book public opinion
those are the two those were in the 20s
and 30s it would it's a lot easier to
propagandize
look at hitler look at stalin uh it is a
lot easier to propagandize uh
population without access to independent
media
it's a lot hard look at look at fdr uh
look at lincoln
uh look at the the confederacy it's a
lot easier to have control of that
population then
than it is now as counterintuitive as it
sounds it's a lot easier to disrupt
a nation's center power centers with
independent media
than yes correct so what the most
powerful weapon is of today is not
firing a nuke it's china
getting a bunch of sock puppets and bots
across social media to undermine
cohesion in the united states i'm all
for undermining cohesion in the united
states as you know i'm for
breaking this country up so that sounds
like a good thing to me i'm just going
to take a step back about this book
there's a
book i recommend everyone read by arthur
hermann who's an amazing historian
his first book was called the idea of
decline in western history
and what he goes through is every 20
years there's a new sect
that says we're at the end of history
the it's
it's very millennialism in the christian
sense like it's it's all going to come
down
get your bootstraps ready and whether
it's it's the hitler version or whether
it's the
the um greta thundberg version it's
always right now it's the end times and
somehow it never is the armageddon so
i'm
very skeptical of these books where the
conclusion always is
now is when things are going to hit the
fan it's always now when things are
about to hit the fan
yeah i thought mister 2006 mr malice
yeah did you see
what um marjorie taylor green recently
said about vaccine passports
the bark of the beast the mark of the
bible i predicted that you predicted
what
that christian fundamentalists are going
to start invoking the mark of the beast
not incorrectly about these vaccines not
incorrectly
yes this is the craziest thing because i
didn't know this until someone super
chatted us
that the mark of the beast was literally
saying you couldn't buy or sell
without it yeah i didn't know that when
i grew up you didn't read revelation
no no yeah
yes yeah yeah kindergarten till end of
fifth grade i was in capital seven heads
and ten horns
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it rose from the
lake or whatever something i read it
recently
and uh i think it was several months ago
someone mentioned on the show that the
prophecies are starting to come true
they're always starting i know i know
and so i actually did it i did a segment
on it for my main channel people have
been more
are more immoral now than they've ever
been yeah
people are saying that like the prophecy
of the lady with this this stuff before
babylon yeah yeah they're like
it's venus and the moon and whatever and
it's like you're looking for patterns
like you were just saying a moment ago
you look for patterns
humans are really good at this what's
that thing that that's called where you
like look at it you can see faces yeah i
forgot that's kind of
paradilia or something like that you can
see a face and everything
so people post these photos on the
internet so i do think it's really
interesting though
that the vaccine passport uh you you'll
need it to buy and trade
and now you've got obviously certain
individuals saying could this be the
mark of the beast
could it be no no it's not
it's a bad idea regardless of the mark
of the beast uh and
the problem is i i i
i'm a fan of hers because i like anyone
who's alone
who says things that are just it's much
more effective
to get your position across in politics
if you come across as unreasonable
than if you're trying to sit down and
have a discussion really why do you say
because there's no talking to her
right so she's not going to sit down
with aoc
and they're not going to co-sponsor
legislation right that's never going to
that's never going to happen
but the aoc wouldn't do it either but
that's of use to the republican party
when they're coming off as intransigent
because then the democrats this happened
twice it happened during the gingrich
congress
uh in in 94 95 this happened during the
debt ceiling crisis under obama when the
republicans like we're not raising that
secret
crisis and we might have to default
those are the only two times they got
budgetary concessions
from the democrats so it's a very useful
thing to come off as
or actually be uh yeah
that's what a lot of people are saying
about donald trump right when it came to
foreign policy
people were like you can't negotiate
with this guy because you know he's out
of it
and so that put pressure on these four
these other world leaders where it's
like what do you do
when you have to negotiate for the best
of your country and you're with donald
trump was going to go
excuse me no no i don't know what that
is we're not no no
no and you're like i do what do i say he
just takes
it's one of the reasons people really
like the guy but i suppose it's a good
point now to be fair i think aoc
isn't going to be you know uh coming to
the table for the democrats either
so marjorie taylor green like i said
comes off like a loon
aoc is not going it is effectively doing
the same thing for democrats so
that's not you don't think so i don't i
i don't i don't think it's the same
thing i don't think
our aoc is saying well no you're right
you know what cause she is saying the
republicans are changing the weather
and their climate change so i just take
it back yeah okay
i'm right i was wrong look she said
under donald trump
these are concentration camps yeah so we
we not we we can see it's funny how they
demonize marjory taylor green and i'm
like yo
you guys had aoc first so you don't get
to come out and complain about marjory
taylor green now i i can i can certainly
point out marjorie taylor green's
posts on facebook and she apologized for
these things she did
she walked it all back i don't okay i
don't let's talk about that okay
if you say that the rothschilds are
building lasers to change the weather
i get how you you're sorry you said it
yeah what i don't get is
walk me through how you got there and
why you no longer are going there
that's what i want to know i don't need
apology so sorry you're saying that it's
quite possible that she's just saying
that she really still believes in the
space lasers changing the weather i
if you believe that space lasers changed
the weather as is your prerogative
what changed your mind al roker now hold
on a second
there there was several studies done
where they used infrared lasers to
uh a seat a cloud seating for cloud
seating
okay that actually happened sure i guess
the issue is when you claim the
rothschilds we're doing it
you know instead of like it was like a
university of berlin or something was
like hey we just realized this thing
happens when you point laser to the sky
tin foil pool no no i i just think it's
like
we what you need to understand about the
insidiousness of these conspiracy
theories is how they
they come from a little seed of truth oh
of course and then someone pours
gatorade on them
because that's what plants crave and
then then they end up with some wacky
idea they can't figure out why things
aren't working properly
and also in their defense we've all
played telephone right
so i can't tell you the number of times
when someone reads an article
and then they'll just repeat it and it's
like that that's not what the article
said at all
i've had people accuse me because i
wrote a book called the new right
of portraying myself as having invented
it i'm like
what are you perceiving me having said
that that you're getting to this
conclusion
yeah other than the rothschilds put
lasers in your brain but look look
i think aoc holds i i think it's fair to
point out thinking about space lasers
from the rothschilds for weather control
is like
very much out there for sure it's out in
space here's the problem
the democrats believe often many equally
as insane things
sure chris hayes has on a guy on his
show on msnbc
is it possible that donald trump has
been a russian asset since the late 80s
and they don't even stop to think that
would imply that trump was still working
for the soviet union which doesn't exist
so who is the asset for you know about
that right yeah but i don't think that's
as crazy as space lasers to be honest
it's not
what i'm saying is well i mean that's
fairly crazy
you want to we'll have we'll have a
crazy off and calculate and quantify
what no it's
come on wait what what's what's more
crazy that one person has been corrupted
or that they're changing the weather for
secret
purposes i i don't think those are
comparable in terms of lunacy
uh and also putin was a kgb agent so
there's there was a lot of
there was a lot of continuity between
the for sure absolutely absolutely no
one's denying that
uh we have satellites we have satellites
with lasers we can use infrared lasers
for cloud seeding we use silver was it
silver iodide for clouds
maybe yeah i thought with silver nitrate
it might be nitrate i could be wrong
silver nitrate there's a silver they use
if you had to play roulette and the
choices are
donald trump has been a russian agent
and the rothschilds are firing lasers to
change the climate
you're saying it's a coin toss no okay
i'm saying that they're both really
crazy and i understand why you think one
is crazier than the other because it
certainly is okay
but i'm also pointing out what they do
is they take morsels of truth to create
this like of course
it's a lot easier to manipulate with
some basis and truth than just something
pure fabrication
1619 project is fabricated garbage and
the left believes this aoc believes this
stuff
it's a creation myth right right she
puts this stuff in policy
so again i i get it i don't i i'm sorry
interrupt you because i'm going to be
pedantic
i don't we don't know that she believes
it it could just certainly be of use to
her
i agree no i think you're right i just
mean that
she uses it yeah so uh this is the point
i was gonna bring up before
under trump she's like these are
concentration camps under biden she
literally said there's no
there's no border crisis and it's
different now because biden is trying to
solve the problem
it's worse than it was under trump it's
not the most amount of migrants
but reuters even said we are looking at
a 20-year spike
in in these these unaccompanied minors
and illegal
illegal immigrants we got new video from
project veritas
children in the dirt under a bridge at
near mcallen
it is bad what they don't want to talk
about because no one knows how to wrap
their heads around this i saw
some there's some articles that mention
this but it's not being made into a
bigger deal and i think it really
should be people talk about rape culture
there's a lot of sexual assaults in
these
uh when you have lots of people who are
not have not citizens who have no access
to the legal system
who you don't know who the heck they are
they're locked in in
close confinement with other people like
in a prison
you're going to have large numbers of
assaults and that to me is what i find
extremely disturbing
and if you actually were concerned about
these people who are being held in these
locations
that should be your priority number one
and it's not and that to me is
very very sick let me ask you something
do you believe marjorie taylor green
genuinely believed those things she was
saying
yes do you think aoc genuinely believes
the things she's saying no
which would you prefer in government i
would prefer
um i can't say what i prefer regarding
government because we get banned
that's fair all right just like we won't
go to the moon with it
but if you're like looking at two people
and you're like you can have the person
who's lying or the person who's crazy
what do you do i would rather have the
person who's lying
because the person who's lying is still
aware of reality and acting in
accordance with
it whereas the person who's crazy it is
a bell curve and if you go four standard
deviations
you might have things like nuclear war
or really so yeah i i agree because
because
the point i want to get to is with a
liar like aoc if she was given unlimited
resources
she would implement some really wacky
crazy system where she tries to pander
to her base
sure but at least it would be like
health care that people just kind of are
upset with
or you know generally bad things that
still exist in reality
if you took someone who's absolutely
crazy and i'm not trying to imply marcia
taylor green would do this but
if you had somebody who believed that
there was like you know nazis on the far
side of the moon with unlimited
resources they would get us building
rockets to the moon to go fight people
who aren't there
and that would just i might rather have
rockets to the moon than like socialized
healthcare because less people are dying
we'll see so now you've made the
argument for the other case exactly
the point i'm making is that you could
have a crazy person just build crazy
things
i don't know maybe they nuked the moon
aoc
someone yeah i mean what are you going
to do sitting around they're going to
expire at some point
so maybe it's not so easy because the
liar is going to make a broken system
and they do the politicians you're just
like how can we make everyone happy i
don't know give them
universal health care that they got to
pay for so they get the individual
mandate here's the easy one that the
republicans are fiscal responsibility
they never vote for a smaller budget
that's a very blatant explicit line
right well you get liars you get crazy
people and sometimes you get both
and i think we have both what's the i
don't know i guess your solution is what
just like anarchy
yeah it's not empowering crazy people
and liars
have you with the power of police i was
thinking we could get rid of
representatives and just use smart
contracts that we vote for as a
collective
why do we have to vote on anything hmm
so that we can agree without having
because some talk to each other but
because sometimes rivers start on fire
sure but rivers start on fire because
the property right of that river isn't
being protected
who the the people owned the river well
that's not a thing
people can't oh who are the people it's
like that's the people who live there
that's the tragedy of the commons is
that when
no one owns it then no one feels
responsibility for it and then everyone
just takes whatever resources they can
and it becomes destroyed
i just i just i there's there's a
logical hole here whenever these
conversations
with like libertarians and objectivists
about owning water
it's like so you're from the cuyahoga
river you're owning water right there
right i'm talking about like a river
apparently the river caught on fire
again
last year what really yeah someone just
told me about it in cuyahoga falls
let's talk about let's talk about
pollution because this is a this is
there's no system where this isn't a
complicated issue
so let's be reasonable here if let's
compare china to the us
uh the chinese river dolphin the goddess
of the river which has been a symbol of
china for centuries has now gone extinct
wow uh the
chinese paddlefish which i think is the
second or the largest
freshwater fish has now gone extinct uh
the
the pollution when you have a uh heavy
centralized economy
which leads to poverty means that
government now is trying to pull
resources from whatever it can
because otherwise the people are
starving so when you have a
bougie society a whole food society
those are the ones who care and have the
ability and wealth
to preserve uh the environment to
preserve
things like river rivers but i agree
with you no
no environmentalist or anyone on earth
is going to have an easy solution
when you're talking about water which
moves and you know you're upstream
upstream and weather and things like
that yeah have you ever seen did i ask
you otherwise other than having a
culture where this is revered and
something that people care about
so i'm i'm very much in favor of
environmental regulations
um i don't i don't know if the solutions
to the world are always going to be easy
or as clear-cut but uh
have you ever seen this video it's by i
think it's youtube channel called grace
still plays i think it's called
where it's a game i think it's called
city state okay and
he decided to just make it pure anarchy
and he thought it was going to be a
bunch of wealthy oligarchs and a bunch
of poor people and drugs and gangs
and this video he's a really funny
youtuber it's really it's a really
really great video because he's shocked
by what happens
and so you watch him play the game and
you watch the game played by other
people and they're like i think we need
environmental regulations okay
let's make sure we have housing for the
poor and you get a mix of poverty and
pollution and you're fighting to keep
things going
so he decides he's gonna have no
regulations no taxes and let people do
whatever he want
and as the game progresses there's no
poverty anymore
everyone's living in luxury and he's
going what's happening
it literally says like it's like
capitalist oligarchy
and there's no poor people everyone's
homes are being built there's ski
resorts everywhere
he's like why are there so many ski
resorts yeah but the poor people have
been made into cold cuts
yeah yeah no no just now they have value
the funny thing is i guess the response
you get from the left is that the game
was clearly made by a capitalist
but in this signal all games are made by
capitalists it's a game it's not a gulag
exactly i just think leisure is a
function of capitalism um
yeah yes fine explain come on
what do you what do you need to explain
like communists don't play baseball
no first of all baseball no baseball's a
west western contrivance but the point
is when you have a contrivance it is
they think it's a waste of time because
it's not working for the culture and
it's i i forget why they specifically
hated baseball but
maybe because it was too american but
yeah when you have these states where
you're supposed to be working for your
fellow man
any spare time that means that's time
you're taking away from poor people and
hungry people you don't need to be
working they particularly attributed
leisure to specialization
yeah which came from capitalism you know
that in north korea there are people
whose job is to be a skateboarder
i've never heard of north korea never
heard of it no no so there's this place
it's a uh it's part of a peninsula you
mean like an island
a place it's not an island it's a
peninsula okay all right and the
northern part
is you know basically it's communist and
but uh in this place there are people
who are
told they have to skate every day by the
government are they competitive
competitive
yeah and so they compete you know i i
guess it's the idea
i don't know that they have the ability
or i'm not entirely sure
i've just seen the photos and like i've
read in skateboarding magazines about
the communists who are like mandated to
be skateboarders well let me break this
down a little bit because as you guys
know i wrote a book on north korea dear
reader
so it's not i mean this is something
that's taking a little bit out of
context athletes in a country that's as
poor as north korea as small as north
korea
is a great way to have reverence on the
world stage because they're saying look
we're tiny north korea we're the size of
well they wouldn't use this example the
size of pennsylvania
and we're taking on russia we're taking
on the united the you know wicked
the wicked u.s imperialist and the [ __ ] i
can't even finish the sentence because
it's a slur
so this is a great and also if you're
coming from nothing now it's your chance
to be a hero of the entire
nation so they are very this is a big
thing during the olympics with the cold
war
this is a very common mechanism for
these states
cuba i talk to people who know people in
the ufc
who think they engage in these kind of
super soldier experiments on kids
uh to make these athletes who are later
growing up to be ufc fighters
because this is their and east german
the east german women's swim team
were all on a certain type of steroid
and they asked the coach they go why'd
they all have such deep voices
and the coach said they came here to
swim not to sing
this was the quote so this is very
common in these uh
centralized countries where you are
basically becoming a hero because it's
kind
it's not expensive to become a great
skateboarder well don't you think that
there's a i'm surprised that
skateboarding is a thing there to be
honest because that's such a capitalist
bougie thing
it's entering the olympics okay it was i
didn't realize uh skateboarding was the
olympic event well it's it's i think the
first
it's it's first olympic event is going
to be coming up in china okay that's why
okay and
over the past decade it's been a huge
point of contention for skateboarders
because
i mean skateboarders become for a long
time very corporate
mainstream cookie cutter and that's kind
of a bummer like a lot of the best
for a while now a lot of the best
skateboarders kind of just like where's
the fun where's the wild where's the
anarchy where's the punk rock
sure it's still there for sure well look
at green day same thing with punk rock
itself
it becomes gap punk sorry joe yeah yeah
but i mean definitely
dookie was good but i mean
you love dookie again i love you you
listen you're listening and always loves
dude
i love what you said michael about
decentral centralized government
indeed because the united states is kind
of decentralized like states
in many ways the cops in a state can be
like get out of here to the feds if they
come and try and bust up their state
laws
and that's very exciting to me that we
yeah i mean you you have i think ohio
basically said to the atf
like we're not going to enforce federal
gun laws i think west virginia just
passed something similar where they're
all basically saying
even though the atf says that they'll
enforce these laws you can't do anything
about it
i i went to the ats website ring about
bump stocks because of this new
court ruling that said a bomb stock is
not a machine gun
and they still say no you cannot have it
so
i do find it interesting when california
legalized medicinal marijuana the dea
still came in and raided these shops
so it is interesting that you can be in
your state and know that you're safe
from your state basically
the feds still come in yeah i was there
for that in l.a and
that was a big fear a lot of times that
the feds would come and raid one of
those shops
and they did i watched videos of it and
there were times that the local cops
would be like get out of here but i mean
it was the feds yes
it's a weird uh i mean what
are your thoughts because i mean you're
coming from a position of anarchy
right when you have a state say it's
legal to do these things and the fed say
we're going to come in and bust them up
anyway i think that's that's wonderful
i mean i think any time you have this
kind of power over this power it just
shows you that law
is a myth and all law means is whether
the
what people don't appreciate is law only
works if you have the will to enforce it
so a lot of times things become legal
not because some politicians went in and
changed the law
but because there was no political will
to enforce the same thing with the
lockdowns
at a certain point it's cuomo said this
i got paid
to read his book and he says in the book
i repeatedly
he says i knew unless i got compliance
from the voluntary compliance from the
vast majority of the population
there was no way i could put this in
place so he's like
it was important for me to murder the
elderly but also to explain to the
population
why we're putting these things into
place so that they would feel
comfortable doing this so this is the
big
uh misconception is that versus 1984
versus brave new world
so much of authoritarianism is not a
function of a gun to your head
like they have in north korea it's a
function of uh the televangelists like
john oliver
and rachel maddow on your tv every night
brother
yeah of course telling you this is good
people who don't do this are bad and
evil or stupid
and good people behave in a certain way
and then you don't have to have the cost
of enforcing compliance
but then yes don't you think at a
certain point you know we're talking
about leisure
you end up with too much ignorance
weakness
laziness and people this this
is i think the strongest criticism of
capitalism and i've come up with it and
i don't have a good answer
we're this comes from the paleo kind of
diet and
mindset if you get to a point where
maslow's hierarchy of needs has been
taken care of meaning you don't have to
worry about where the next meal is going
to come from
you don't have to worry about the roof
over your head you don't have to worry
about your health really
your brain is still wired to think in
terms of resource scarcity
our brains are still in terms of get
more get more get more and if you don't
actually have
problems in an evolutionary sense where
no predator is going to eat you you have
plenty of food
you have shelter your brain is going
this is my hypothesis
is going to find problems to validate
its emotion
in the same way that depression anxiety
people don't realize this
the emotion comes first the depression
the anxiety then your brain tells you
oh you're depressed because you don't
have a job there's plenty of people who
have a job who aren't depressed
it's just your mind tells you exactly
what it needs to do
to validate this emotion to perpetuate
itself it's like in the matrix
when smith tells i think he's talking to
morpheus and he says we gave you
paradise and your brain
injected it yes that's exactly it and
i've talked about i talked about before
several years ago i did a segment where
i said um our generation has lost
purpose
and one of the reasons that's why one of
the reasons uh jordan peterson was such
a threat
to the left because yeah you had these
kind of two factions i saw that were
large factions not necessarily the
parent factions
the woke left the social justice
warriors etc
people without purpose they found their
religion it was their fight that must be
fought and it gave them reason for being
it also gave them status because if i am
a lowest status
white person this is the only metric i
have by assuming dominance over somebody
else
i can be violently anti-racist and have
something to hold over somebody else
i can't compete with them on any other
level so you you end up with also
also follower counts followers on the
other side you had listless young men
you know sitting in their basements
playing video games well this was good
because it was the demon it was the
enemy he was the villain
for many of these woke people to point
at them and call them big
bigots jordan peterson came along and
gave these people purpose
responsibility told them find the
heaviest thing you can carry and carry
it
not the guy's perfect but a lot of
people then started you know hearing
this message of self-help
and that kind of it not only and
independence
absolutely meaning you're it's coming
from inside instead of the people around
you and that's dangerous
because they're the ones who are around
you and they want to recruit from a pool
of purposeless individuals yes
but if people found purpose from within
and they no longer longer found purpose
from being accepted by a cult
well then they then they created actual
resistance so jordan peterson had to be
villainized in every competition it was
incredible to watch his interviews
with i think kathy newman particularly
where she was like dumbfoundedly
confused at what he was doing she just
didn't understand you're
why are you giving them purple so you're
saying she's a nazi so what i'm saying
is
she no i wouldn't um like this guy
looking at it but she will i'm gonna be
on jordan peter's
show on monday and it's gonna be very
exciting oh yeah yes um
but she her confusion cathy newman like
why
why was she kidding the fact that she
was confused was was really weird
well she wasn't confused she was
perceiving things
that made sense in her context oh yeah
yeah from her she was translating yeah
she was thinking he's an articulate
right because he's awkwardly saying
what she agrees with already she's
incapable of perceiving other kind the
number of people
who are incapable of the slightest bit
of empathy
is through the roof they are absolutely
incapable of seeing other perspectives
there are people who tell you the
straight face why would you be
interested in
knowing what osama bin laden wanted and
it's like well if you want to destroy an
enemy don't you at least want to know
their motivation and that makes no sense
then they think
if you're reading what bin laden wanted
therefore you agree with him and it's
like that's not even the implication at
all no article that's why they want to
ban all these books yes
these look this is one of the biggest
challenges we face
people who just i i wonder if we're
seeing a separate
midwitz is maybe not the right word but
maybe the right word
right so people who are was it slightly
above yeah average 115 iq slightly above
average but not smart enough
right we're talking someone let's
interrupt you it's like a guy who's 511.
he's tall in that he's above average
there's no circumstance where his height
would be
noticeable or of interest but so if
you're marginally intelligent
you might be the smartest person in a
group but no one will ever be impressed
by your mind
so we're talking about this earlier in
the george floyd
case there's a video where the cop is
walking george floyd out of uh
uh you know he's walking around the
street where there's the surveillance
footage and the cop says something like
you've got foam on your mouth are you on
something and floyd says no nothing man
then he's like
why you have foam on your mouth and
floyd says i was hooping earlier
hoops shooting hoops it's a reference of
basketball pbs reported this as
you know he'd been playing basketball
maybe he got dehydrated whatever that
means well
jack bosovic posted this and as a joke i
pulled up the urban dictionary
definition specifically highlighting
hooping is a reference to smuggling
narcotics
up your you know your well it's not you
know your rear end
yeah in a bag and so
on the urban dictionary post it says get
your
hoop and mug because whatever word you
search for they tell you to buy the
merch for it
so i made a joke in response to him
because i've been very silly on twitter
saying don't forget to buy your hoop and
mug and then i showed the urban
dictionary thing
and these leftists were like tim is so
dumb he doesn't know that hooping means
basketball
and another person was like for someone
who claims to be from the city it's
shocking
and i said you guys are the kind of
people that thought i was serious i said
impeach the queen
yes when we have people like that
they're active in the
in the conversation but not smart enough
to perceive
their sarcasm or humor or maybe the
nuance to the conversation
and they vote on these these ideas it's
like
when you when you mentioned they didn't
want to understand osama bin laden
sure the similarity i see there is that
their only thought is
smash with club like they see a bad guy
hit with club hit with club
and so when someone makes a joke they go
that's the same thing as the bad guy hit
with club hit with club and you're like
there's a
whole bunch of com complex nuance and
jokes and humor
and they lack the capability to
understand isn't this a huge source of
optimism
no but think i'm not kidding all the
dumb people yeah but think about it who
would you rather go against skynet
or a bunch of guys with clubs this is a
no-brainer
so tim you've correctly identified it
although there's not a problem behind
their keyboards
although they're on twitter they're not
literally dressed like fred flintstone
you're dealing with thousands of
millions of people whose only mindset to
an opponent is
smash with clubs clubs aren't clubs are
such a bad weapon they're not even in
clue
so yeah this is a this is why i'm so
optimistic about the future
because you innocently just now
correctly identified the nature of the
enemy
and this isn't some great uh terminator
from the future
this is fred flintstone yes but there
are people who are smart
who have realized without principle they
don't have any
to begin with they can weaponize the
hive and use it as a weapon
correct they can weaponize it but humans
run the country in the world and not
bees
so i agree with you bees are dangerous
and bees can kill people and they're not
something to be taken lightly even in
terms of insects i'm not
being facetious at all but at a certain
point it's like
there's a ceiling there's only so much
you could do with bees yeah you could
have dogs that shoot beads out of their
mouth but other than that it's
it's but look classify the hive yeah
perhaps
you can be smart you can throw wrench in
the spokes you can figure things out
music
but yeah but there's something or you
could become the queen
maybe we all but how do you become the
queen of a hive of people who
well you're going to need psychological
power baby some eyeliner people who
become the queen
are the emotional manipulators they have
no principles
you could have principles of an
emotional manipulator yeah it's called a
wife
i suppose then what you're saying is we
as smart individuals should recognize
i didn't say we were smart individuals
let's up for words in my mouth okay
so what you're saying is those who
[Laughter]
so what we should do is live like
lobsters should we then
speak honestly to those who we feel as
perceptive and understanding but then
lie to the dumb masses to control them
to gain power no
i think we should be honest that we're
going to try to ask me what i'm saying
with them okay michael you answered it
you know what michael is saying it's not
you know i do want to hear your response
oh
um i think we just honestly acknowledge
that we are going to manipulate
people with this psychic power and do it
for righteousness and be honest about
our own faults no
i would say and uh hotep jesus has this
quote which is not particularly unique
to him to realize you're behind enemy
lines
study what the communists did back in
the 20s and 30s study what gay people
had to do for decades
and figure out how to pass so when
you're talking to someone who's
this sounds like the cop hit with club
once you've identified you're dealing
with that kind of person
you talk to them in a certain way once
you're dealing with people who are
slightly red-pilled whether they're on
the far left like jimmy dore
or somewhere else you know you could
have a conversation and it's gonna go
somewhere
so the big mistake people have and this
is a function of going to a government
school
where everyone's treated as one class
both in the literally class but also the
same kind of population
is thinking everyone thinks like you and
everyone's wired like you they're not
wow so you have to realize yeah there
are some bees and there are some wasps
wasps aren't bees at all they're
actually ants and realize okay i'm
dealing with this kind of thing
i have to address them in a certain way
if i'm dealing with somebody else i have
to dress them
in a different way and that's just and
gay people do this for a long time
comedy said do this in a very long time
and black people had to do this
mulattoes this has happened some in the
1920s the home renaissance
these are things that you have to study
and figure out and and figure out and
here's the other thing because they're
not bright
they're very big on picking up words
that's why
the term for african american used to be
afro-american and then previous ones
which i don't even know if i can say
anymore
the point is they kept changing these
terms because they would know as they
roll out the new term
if you're using a new language you're
part of the in-group so it's very easy
just adopt their language when you need
to to pass
and they'll it'll be like like
terminator they see you use the right
terms they'll leave you alone and move
on
and then you could just go about your
business and well not easy to do but
they've had a long they're playing long
con
and they've had over 100 years at this
that's so my my understanding of
this stuff having been it for like 10
years you're right i've i've talked with
some activists and made some points
legitimate points based on their own
ideology
and caused people on facebook to back
down and apologize notably like there
was an argument a legitimate political
argument
that i was having on facebook this was
like a year two ago where one person was
basically talking about
social justice and race issues and
critical race theory and i started
arguing against this saying freedom
liberty etc
and they were like you don't understand
when i pointed out as everybody knows
the meme that tim poole was actually
mixed race they immediately apologized
and started arguing with me and agreeing
with me because their own ideology
essentially dictated it
when i said if it is uh incumbent upon
the minority to define something that
you right now as a as a white person
hear me and recognize my opinions based
on my experience and they said
i'm so sorry i didn't realize i guess
you're right and so it's particularly
insulting
but i said that to make a point about
there are if you truly believe this then
wouldn't you then agree with me and
argue with me and they said
actually yeah i will they don't truly
believe anything
they're just using they don't use
language the same use the way you use
language i talked about this with james
lindsay who was on my show you're
welcome this week
they use language as a form of asserting
status and dominance
so at a certain point you have to
realize there's no mind there
and there's not really a point in
engaging it's just power games and
what do you need power games for when
you don't want to be part of the beehive
i don't want to
be a part of that stupid game i don't i
don't look i worked for non-profits
and the thing is you are part of it it's
social order and it that what you're
explaining michael is
is basically no you must understand and
and you gotta let me know hard times
so so my point was what we're being
described told to do is when we're in
their system because we're behind enemy
lines we need to just speak their
language and i won't do that i did that
at non-profits they said here's how you
communicate with people i understood the
sale i understood the pitch
and there are some circumstances where
i'll put it this way i'll be polite you
know i was at a bar recently and someone
told me they're a huge fan of kamala
harris
and instead of saying like yeah kamala
hair's so great i was like i am not a
fan
but i'll be polite i don't want to you
know get into any contentious you know
arguments over why
and she asked me like no what do you
think and i was like kamala harris kept
you know minorities kept in prison
beyond their sentence to use as
dollar an hour slave labor for fighting
wildfires
i think that's wrong i'm willing to say
it i get it's going to offend their
delicate sensibilities but
i don't i don't i don't i don't care to
do that but what's the upside of
engaging with this person
um i want to keep out any specific
details
but there was okay that's different okay
but i'm saying in general if there's
someone at a bar and they're like i'll
have kamala harris unless you're trying
to
take her to bed it's just like okay lady
i don't care what you think no but
there's issues of
ish instances of business relations
that's very different when it's fair
you're talking to someone and trying to
figure out if you can work with someone
and if they come out and say these
things my simple answer is i'm not going
to do this i think the
behind enemy lines metaphor makes me
think of hard times make strong men
when you're in a desperate fighting for
survival situation you have to use their
language
and we don't have that in this society
because we haven't been in hard times so
we're like you know i'm not going to
play that game but it's like
this is a fight for our lives this is
this daily grind is real and people are
dying on the street people's houses are
getting burned and that's just
in the united states yeah i don't know
if this is true or not but i remember
being told when i was kid
the symbol of the fish where it came
from and
there's a bunch of jesus fishing yeah
yeah there's stories about like jesus
and two fish and then there's
the dawning of the age of pisces i
thought that was dr seuss what
one fish two fish but what someone told
me is that
what they would do is because christians
were were
persecuted when they met someone they
would draw a curved line
in front of them and if the other person
finished a curved line it would make the
shape of a fish and they knew
that it was safe to talk to them about
about what they believed i don't know if
that's actually true or not
i just was told that by some religious
folk when i was like very young about
how it was like they had to keep this a
secret
and so they would draw the fish symbol
between each other and that's like it's
an it's an interesting idea of what you
were mentioning about what people have
to do to learn and navigate systems
where they're basically
outgrouped and threatened and they could
be destroyed and and also there's a huge
asymmetry between cost cost and benefit
you know what i mean like
the benefit of this person is very low
but the cost could be your life
so you really need to figure out how to
do the dance i mean for me
i'm gonna mind my own business and i'm
going to keep speaking how i want to
speak and i'm going to tie everyone to f
off and then if they come for me you
know what i don't know whatever
that can work it comes to the point
where youtube is like you can no longer
say that like tim poole you know you you
can it is now banned to defend kyle
written now so i'll be like yeah i'm
banned
yeah every everyone which did it twitch
did it you literally can't defend
cowardice on twitch is that right
so we had destiny on the show and he's a
leftist and we we we had a debate he's
very much into critical race theory
he was banned from the partner program
for defending kyle rittenhouse it's a
leftist guy and he said
it was the clearest case of self-defense
i've ever seen they banned him from the
partner program well twitch is owned by
amazon and amazon runs the servers for
twitter so maybe we'll see some
twitter active interactivity in that
vein but i i'm also very hopeful
that now that so many people are aware
of what amazon's power is in this
in this context you think of amazon as
products you don't think of it as
running servers and booting off
um gab what was the other one sorry
parlor
uh that they're they're already i'm sure
are people in place who are like okay we
need to create workarounds
so amazon could never do this again yeah
and it's just going to be a matter of
couple of years at most in my opinion oh
yeah i would love it decentralized yes
but i mean
we're talking about doing it am i wrong
that there's lots of people who are
trying to you're right
okay yeah how about we go to super chats
my friends if you haven't already
smash that like button seriously do it
it helps if you're listening on itunes
or spotify leave us a good review give
us five stars
and go to timcast.com become a member
because we're gonna have a bonus segment
for members only coming up
at the after this show usually around 11
we get it up but also don't forget to
share this show on youtube subscribe
we're so close
to 1 million subscribers we're like 10k
away and uh
would love to break it with all of your
help everybody who's watching what is
this what i was just excited
oh yeah we're so close michael made eye
contact it was
it was a moment youtube will send us
that gold
gold award and then we'll be banned in a
month but we'll see
yes smash that like button let's read
these super chats let's see what y'all
got saying
what you all got going on we all got
saying honey what do they like best
about me
there you go uh please everyone super
chat what you like uh best about michael
malus
that is important uh you know i got a
bunch of emails from people
that said what i like best about michael
malus is and we actually hired a guy
because of it
good i hope he had a good answer he did
have a good answer last night
uh i don't remember that it wasn't good
no it was you won't remember it if it
was good but it was also interesting
that
many of these people saw you tweet this
you know so for those who don't
understand the context
there was a i think you you you uh you
you um
reference someone we should have i
recommended it and recommendation
usernames lockoutdays on youtube
and then you said you know the email
better say what i like best about
michael malus is and then i said if we
don't see that we throw in the trash as
a joke
and then we got a small handful of
people who were paying attention so i
was like
attention to detail is extremely
underrated in terms of hiring being
because it's
a conversation and if someone's being i
hate this word being proactive about
like well just in case
he asked this question let me give him
an answer that's someone who's ahead of
the game
absolutely yeah i mean they were paying
attention so i was like that that shows
this these these are
people who are likely active in the
space they know what's going on they're
following
similar people it's a good sign all
right let's get some super
uh read some super chats i need to drink
more water oh yeah spencer pride at home
says tim i'm still waiting on my tinfoil
hat shirt any news when it comes out
man i am just dropping the ball on this
one the tin foil hat i'ma gorilla oh
yeah
i'll get it i'll get it done they can
what you can do is go to malice
shirts.com and get
my covet positive shirt
can you can you do can you do me a favor
and write down tinfoil hat gorilla so i
remember
i will write this down i have the
tinfoil hat in my house alex jones
alexis
we have a version of the gorilla hat
okay and we're going to make a
probably do it like a limited edition i
i think the diamond hands gorilla will
be going away soon as well the iron girl
will be around forever
but i think the special versions will
only leave up for like part of meme
let's give a shout out to the guy who
made that video pink trip which one was
that the
gorilla video that he when he made he
made a little uh a video of
you and me and alex yeah yeah i wanted
to use that as an ad
to promote the show on youtube and run
that as an ad like watch this
yeah have could people confuse like what
i guess i'll click it
i don't know what those videos are great
stuff all right let's read some more
never made one of me though
the curly afro says just like the states
that paid blood and treasure to enter
the union so did puerto rico
for 104 years we have paid the price of
admission we earned statehood
statehood por favor by the way apes
together strong
there you go that's true all right a lot
of people some people shout out tom
mcdonald would love to have him on the
show we'll see if that happens
make 1984 fiction again he says
your four o'clock segment i mostly
agreed with but he was a criminal
despite the fact that he was
he was a drug addict being addicted to
drugs it's not a disease it's a choice i
was
addicted to opiates for eight years my
brother for years and he's no longer
with
us i just think i hear what you're
saying
i think okay it's a crime fine but
when you get detained it should be like
we're bringing you to a clinic we're not
going to put you in a cell and we're not
going to take away your rights we want
to make sure we can help you get through
this you know what i mean and i know
this argument but it's not
always an informed choice like you don't
know none of us in this room i
can't speak for you guys none of us know
what it's like to go through withdrawal
from heroin
so you might know theoretics sorry you
might know theoretically okay withdrawal
really sucks
but unless you've like here's a parallel
example that's not going to be as
political
unless you've had to deal with suicide
literation you're not going to
understand what that feels like not
i mean god forbid i hope none of you
ever had to deal with that go ahead and
i have to interject here
uh because i worked in a cardiac unit
and i worked with people who were
withdrawing from
multiple different drugs including
alcohol they actually closed down a ward
close to my house
because too many babies were being born
there that were already addicted to
heroin
you don't know what hand you're dealt
you don't know what people are dealing
with
and past a certain point it is a
physiological dependency
yeah we we got a very very important
super chat here from gem r
wow serious stuff he says for
malice looking dapper enjoyed his chat
with james james lindsay recently too
look and dapper uh michael thank you
yeah oh
i love it mk painter says michael tell
me your best radio free
armenia joke is that gonna get us in
trouble or what is that i don't know
what that means i'm not all right great
radio free armenia i'm sorry i'm not
trying to be gl i don't know what that
means
socratic disciple says tim your idea
about preventing people from funding
candidates outside their district is
flawed
just give money to a relative who lives
in that area and have them make the
donation for you
aha but that is actually a felony oh
yeah you
if you if you try to donate to a
candidate if you donate to a candidate
and then i'm like okay now i'll give ian
money now ian can do it it's called the
felony
is that what happened to dinesh d'souza
it happens a lot of people because
basically the limit's pretty low or it
was
and then it's like 800 yes so if it's
2800 i'll just find i'd be a bundler
whatever i think this is what they're
doing
i'll find 10 people i'll write out the
28 thousand dollar check and just put
down their names
so this was a workaround but this is not
something that they got away with yeah
no it's a crime to do that so
i i definitely think like i think the
gist of the conversation
especially after sleeping we talked
about it my current position is
i do think it's a problem that a handful
of billionaires
can suppress the will of so many people
i just don't know what this what the
solution is because it's
way too much of a complicated problem
let's have a look conversation if i ever
come on
because this is something that is very
complicated and i don't know that there
is an alternative
and i don't know and i don't know that
the millions of people have a will
oh spicy i'm turned off by popularity
contests especially when it comes to
running the show especially because i
keep losing them
aj says hey tim first time super chatter
look into smartland's cryptocurrency
built off the stellar platform right on
des
says told my friend i got red pill last
summer out of curiosity he googled it
and thought i became a misogynist and
white supremacist despite being mexican
where's the lie
yeah that was the article no lies
detected
you got you i mean that's why i don't
like saying red pill i just say
you know a realization man i i realized
the media wasn't telling me the truth
it's easy
and arrest not the same as a red pill
though well how would you describe it
uh being red pilled let me see if i can
quote my book accurately
being red pilled is the realization that
is what is presented by fact by the
corporate press
isn't is in actuality a carefully
designed narrative and
uh meant to keep some very unpleasant
people in power yeah
butters oregano says two things malice
needs a beanie that matches his tie
hold on hold on hold on what what is
this you get a super chat and you get
two things one thing per chat you guys
got the wallets open him up
he says mouse needs a beanie that
matches his tie and the difference
between a fiscal elite using their money
to buy advertisements and someone
watching your show is the choice to
watch your show versus being forced to
visually imbibe the propaganda
okay orion
nero says how far do you guys believe
they'll try pushing the censorship
nonsense
who could say what when they're eating
each other alive for the power
as far as they can the other crowd are
going to break any rules the only thing
that stops it is going to be counter
power
that's just inertia yeah yeah i think
you're right about that yeah that's
another
why wouldn't they they're clearly
totalitarian in their world view like
there's there's no make no bones about
it
any country and if something bad is
happening anywhere on earth it's
somehow their business so there's no
limits what we got a big super chat
that's not a big one it's just one of
the best is it adrian hi adrian
bug hq for us says i own a cricket farm
in nc
named bug hq please check us out for
your reptile food guys
tim i'd love to send you some free
crickets for chicken city
yes it's fun to watch them attack a few
hundred absolutely we will be reaching
out to you guys
why would you why would you want to pay
those exorbitant cricket prices for
something the farmer probably spit in
a fair point that was a whole simpsons
joke about orange juice
crickets are so expensive so the farmer
probably spit in
oh man what back when simpsons were good
yeah
that was when there was a plague that
hit springfield they were soccer flew in
yeah yeah the juicer yeah graf von tearl
says it's a complete disgrace that we're
more likely to get more matter-of-fact
news about america from british and
australian news sources
but why is that a disgrace i'm gonna
okay
this this triggered me a little bit you
are expect you are being blue pilled
if if it's like when the the guy's a
player and he tells the girl i'm not a
player baby i just want to get to know
you
of course the corporate press is going
to tell you we're honest
we're here to tell you the news about
america why would you believe them at
face value
good question i'm sorry i just i just
saw a super chat
and i i'm just losing it right pops
vindaloo says rabbit butt cut
what we were talking about rabbits
eating their own butt cut and so he
super chatted
rabbit butt cud rbc
oh man rabbits are gross they're not
easy to care for a lot of people think
they are and they're not friendly
and they're always panicky amy sedaris
is always into rabbits
as pets all right let's see i can't this
is in cyrillic i think i can't read it i
know how to read it
uh it says you will die in a fiery plane
crash here erin
the backwards and backwards n a n
e k i can't read it when you're reading
in english
what about helen backwards r that means
yeah the line through it i'm kidding i
don't know
uh so they say and it says rubles what
insane historical trivia will we get
today from michael
maybe some opinions on batco
i don't know mac what m-a-k-h-n-o
h-mach botco batco
i don't i'd have to see it and survive i
only learned how to read russian in
college so i
i'm very bad at it well they just wasted
their rules no there you go jmac says i
had opioids prescribed to me for back
pain following a military work accident
your body starts to build a resistance
to the prescribed amount and it feels
like you have to take more just to ease
the pain
i just stopped taking them just to spare
my body permanent damage
wise move i was i was given percocets i
took one
and it was just like floating on a cloud
man like you said
it was like methadone once this is not
an endorsement of taking no person no no
i'm telling you this
is the danger of taking percussion and
so i said the pain
i'd rather have the pain absolutely
you're good here's the thing you're
gonna have the pain now or you're gonna
have it later
so you'd rather pay the little pain now
short term
than the years of paying on that
mortgage yep and hey thc
and medical marijuana is such a blessing
i think that this country has yet to
fully adopt but it also is a painkiller
it's like a natural homeopathy what do
you know about weed
i've heard about it check this out i
read about it hey this is a really
important point uh someone brought in
super chat we didn't get to i did
mention this on my four o'clock segment
the purpose of pleading the fifth could
be because he sold the drugs that could
possibly have caused the overdose
overdose death of george floyd oh sure
he could be charged with manslaughter
especially if there's an acquittal of
chauvin
that actually is third degree murder i
believe if you uh so i read through the
laws
it says if you supply someone with a
substance a controlled substance that
results in their death you it's a murder
charge
he pled the fifth because the defense is
going for he died from the overdose and
they were probably gonna be like
and he did it uh i'm not a lawyer none
of us are but i'm gonna just throw this
out there because this is something i
thought was pretty standard practice you
plead the fifth what happens when they
give you immunity
can't they force you to testify yep so
this might just have been a pause
right so they'll offer him immunity and
then he'll be forced to be subpoenaed
and forced to testify
and then the defense will say did you
sell him these drugs and then he'll look
to the jury and say reasonable doubt
by the way i also want to point out this
speaks the anarchist idea that equality
under the law is a complete lie
because if there was equality in the law
there's no such thing as forcing someone
to testify because you can't acquit them
of a crime just because you want to get
somebody else yeah
everyone has to be tried or no one right
gray g and uh giannikos first
super chat might as well be on my
birthday happy birthday gray the
province of bc has decided to shut down
indoor dining so my family business in a
town of 4 000 people has to pay for the
rise in case numbers
predominantly in the big cities p.s
trevor sucks
who's trevor oh he sucks yeah he's the
worst that's what i heard yeah
i just now heard that yes trevor oh
god i don't ever want to hear his name
again huh i'm going to read the super
chat
i'm going to read the super chat that's
your job but you might not be happy
about it well then you'll be very
unhappy about it
oh yeah yeah i'm reading it anyway eric
miller says so michael
you say we didn't deserve donald trump
now do we deserve joe biden
okay oh god eric god help me
you're right you're right you're right
i'm sure no no no no no no i didn't read
the last part
okay i didn't say okay god damn eric
you're worse than trevor
[Laughter]
all right you ready for the last i don't
think i am also love the clark kent look
you got going on
i don't know what he's talking about
yeah i don't get that either
yeah i don't get that part um my quote
which tim has picked up on very well in
lydia as well and i'm assuming ian
is whenever i have a trump tweet or now
he's the press releases i say
we don't deserve him that could be read
as
he's awful or like we don't deserve this
or
that he's awesome and it's intentionally
both
because he is awful in many ways and he
is awesome in other ways
there you go all right alex moore says
no we don't deserve a president
or any governor well you do you do
what's his name
alex eric eric eric you're worse than
trevor you deserve
gitmo governors to gitmo.com
all right alex moore says this super
chat is for your members only rant
on not backing down last night it was
absolutely awesome
when does the dating site kick off i
don't think we're gonna make a tim cass
dating site
but um yeah i got mad i was yelling
i was just like i'm so sick of i growing
up in chicago
and seeing people just abuse and beat
it's just like
it's very much just like a superhero
movie where you watch the villain
beating down the poor people and the
hero comes in and he makes them stop and
i'm like nah dude there's no superheroes
here
uh uh
there's one villains are real but the
superheroes are only on tv
that means you have to stand up to these
people and if you
did things would be different it'd be
very different if people were just brave
enough okay
first of all i think that's that's the
my favorite thing i've heard you say
today
and i'm gonna build on that to another
point i've given a couple of talks to
young kids about networking
and one of the my favorite piece of
advice to give them i say
if you know someone is having their
birthday and they're not doing anything
take them out for doing dinner and do it
for selfish reasons and the audience
laughs and i go i'm serious because
the guy who takes people out for their
birthday is awesome
you could be that person yeah all it's
costing you is 30 bucks 40
bucks you have that power maybe you're
not gonna be
literally superman but you could still
be a better version of yourself
and when you're a better version
yourself happiness and success follows
and everyone has that capacity only a
few almost except for trevor
he's garbage i know isn't it i read that
there's there's look you know there's
only a few people who would ever live
up to like the strength of superman you
know what i mean this is like a small
very few
very few girls
some people they try to claim or
or or masquerade perhaps as someone as
great as
everyone but they're deceivers and
manipulators once a while you get one
person you sound like martin luther
and they're lies
well i'll just tell you this man you got
to be careful about the the the false
superheroes you know yeah who who
brandish themselves the psychos of the
heroes you mean
you mean sully sully yeah failed
muhammad
i don't know the pilot oh that's right
right he couldn't fly the plane or
whatever
he wanted to fly into the empire state
building and he had to land into a river
east river all right yes i see
he's a stutterer some people call me dim
fool which is always uh uh
is always original and unique sonny
james says i'd love to argue about
cultural issues
but i beg you tim or michael please do a
segment on biosurveillance and the
powerful interests
involved in backing tsa 2.0 the new fake
war on germs
oh that's a great topic that that that
was a great topic thank you
i mean it's a long long conversation we
have to do some research
but this is very smart this is next-gen
totalitarianism i would like to watch
you guys with ben stewart talk about
that he has a lot of research on that
have you uh have you ever talked with
jimmy dore have like you've done a show
with him uh we
we follow each other um i've slid into
his dms
no reply jimmy jimmy's a good dude i
know i'm a fan
um i've i've talked on periodically i've
been on a show i just
must be nice yeah well you know see
us us you know people up here in the
clouds you mean like me and jordan
sometimes don't i call him jordan
[Laughter]
sorry jim fool no no time for this
get all those beanies off your bed
[ __ ] i love i love
pimp tool and dim fool because it's like
you know what the best of those is
tronal dump
someone said that i'm like oh my god
this is actually clever but you know
what you know what's funny to me like
when i see people tweet pimp tool or dim
fool or whatever or tin pool is a dim
fool
it's just like seeing chickens cluck you
know what i mean it's super clever
there's like there's like you didn't say
a thing to me right but i think it's
that's very tongue-in-cheek and kind of
ribbing you it's not serious right no a
lot of the pimp tool one is serious okay
but you know like the gym fool is
clearly a fans of the show who are
ribbing with you no no like it's the
left who started
i thought i thought that was because of
my knock-knock joke i think it was oh
it's been on forever a long time
fool really yeah yeah yeah oh i thought
it was my joke okay i'm telling you a
lot of those people are taking from my
joke oh i i think it's hilarious it
makes me laugh every time i see it yeah
your barrel laughs tim yeah i don't
understand
um i don't understand what it is about
these like these leftists when they come
at me on twitter or they try and insult
me
that i think well you know what i'm
gonna stop it's clear they're just
saying it so their friends see it
because it impacts me and like sometimes
they
trust you i i i of all people know what
you mean because i get that too and i'm
just like what do you think this
when people tell you like sit down and
shut up i'm like literally what do you
think this is going to accomplish on
twitter you're not in my house i am
sitting down i'm in my underwear all the
time
so how are you in position to tell me to
shut up but it's a net positive
like the so when i first you know
started getting twitter followers and
stuff during occupy wall street
my initial reaction in the first week or
so was anxiety no joke
i had never had this level of attention
all of a sudden people were tweeting at
me like crazy insulting me and called me
crazy things half of them were nice half
of them were bad
and i was like what is this and then
very quickly i was like
oh these people are dumb and i started
ignoring it they're bees but then
a week or two later i started getting
excited every time i saw it you know why
because you were sexually attracted to
bees yeah i was just like wow this is
great
um because every baby every single time
these people were tweeting at me i
started to realize i was like man am i
am i doing something important
right like am i all of a sudden one of
these people that like influencer
yeah you're like wow yeah i started
realizing that hate didn't matter
because it doesn't change my opinions
right
it just means that my opinions matter to
people
hate it the love and the hate is like a
social study and not to take either of
them personally
it can blow your ego up or grip it down
if you let it take it personally don't
but just look at the waves of emotions
that are occurring and then kind of
incorporate that into how you're
behaving and try and
yeah modulate people ask me sometimes
how i deal with it and
i don't think i have i'm good at dealing
with in this sense because being a new
yorker all my life
if a homeless person comes up to you and
starts screaming things even if those
insults are things you might be insecure
about or
are true it's not going to permeate your
only thought in your mind is i have to
get away from this homeless person
before it escalates or i don't care this
case
so if someone comes at you on twitter
and says blah blah blah it's just like
i didn't know you existed three seconds
ago you don't like me
that's fine like you don't i'm not for
everyone go live your best life and i
don't
why would you think i would care i was
thinking about
playing a song with different different
qualities of instruments like
maybe you need the right quality of
instrument to really appreciate the
music
yeah yeah yeah that's a great that's a
great metaphor like a theremin
yes
says i'm in the military and now being
told that if i own any cryptocurrency i
need to sell it or risk
or or risk losing my security clearance
same with marijuana stocks i find that
to be ridiculous
it's not ridiculous if you're signing up
for the military they own you
yeah man so it's not ridiculous at all
so
ghost crusader says tim paypal can snap
their fingers and end your career
very much absolutely true yep and so
what i try any horror stories
but so your banking institutions can and
these other platforms can
what i'm saying is we need to minimize
the links in the chain
because if you have 10 different
services any one of them so you're
creating more risks so minimize that
or i mean to be pedantic you want to
maximize the links
so if one link breaks you've got 80
backup links you want to maximize the
amount of chains yeah different links
so what i'm saying is if you have a
business right right not one yeah
where you upload to three channels then
you've got you know all of these
different companies
i guess i should say
it's not necessarily a good analogy if
you're on locals then
it's you two locals yes and then you
have your payment processor
and then locals has dns the problem is
that with each and every person
resting in the back basket of patreon
locals or subscribes or any of these
platforms
it's putting weight on their chain
between their services
and at any point they might be like we
gotta we gotta you know toss some people
out of
the bucket otherwise we go down with
everyone else minimize that so that
there's one chain with a bunch of people
dangling
evenly and everything's fine well one
person might get thrown out by somebody
else but
i just want to minimize who has control
over over over this i hardly endorse
this product or event
all right let's see where we're at jay
stewart says tim by banning people they
divide how much support they can receive
corporations can work together and
provide a cheap central location for
access
but if people want to support you and
crowder the cost has suddenly doubled
well how much are you willing to put
forward to defend
the ideas you like or the shows that you
like i mean there are people who who
spend just without even thinking about
it
they're probably spending 100 bucks
between their disney plus their netflix
their hulu
and you know paramount or whatever cbs
all these different things 10 15 bucks
how much are you willing to spend for
independent channels i think one of the
problems is this is why we want to do
shows
someone says it's 10 bucks a month to be
a member of timcast.com for this one
show
and then it's you know 10 bucks a month
for for mug club and then 10 bucks a
month
now it's like i want five shows and it
costs me 100 bucks whereas i can get
300 shows from one netflix or from one
prime or whatever so that's why i'm like
we need to have as many shows as
possible
under you know timcast.com membership so
we're gonna have shows we're gonna have
documentaries
i'm gonna hire some reporters we're
gonna get writers and we're gonna make
this whole big massive thing
i i what i was shocked at and this is
because of my
senior citizen status how many people
there are
who are tripping over themselves who see
i guess this is kind of like in a
restaurant like no one doesn't tip like
it's just a given you're gonna tip how
many people and this is something
happened very recently internet culture
are very eager to be like i own a
business i'm a stay-at-home mom
it's important to me that you're taking
those bullets and up front
so let me give you those five bucks a
month because you're saying things that
i can't i didn't realize
how many of those people are there and i
i they pay my rent and i'm
very very grateful and you know
this is kind of my immigrant brain if
you've never met me and you're giving me
that five bucks that's like buy me a
drink that is such a sign of respect and
i do not take it for granted and it
really is very moving when i get to be
that guy it is like
dragon
[Laughter]
my virginity just came back uh
i'm gonna miss pronounce your name again
he says gray giannikos mispronouncing my
name as a sign of racism
but hey thanks for the extra super chat
so
it's greek i think i will admit to
mispronouncing your name
clayton from illinois says michael did
you really mean that all
cops are criminals or was that
hyperbolic all cops are criminals
they're not all
on the take they're not all corrupt but
if you look at there was this footage
i'm sure you probably talked about in
your show tim
i think it was hollander belgium where
there are people in a park
and there was like an older man who's
maybe 70 and there's a cop running by
him on horseback clubbing him over the
head and he was why are you laughing
it's a ridiculous story it's crazy oh
but i mean it was extremely disturbing
to see old people getting clubbed and
his head was smashed open
that's the good apple the good apples
aren't the ones on the take
they're the ones who smile and nod and
follow orders and those
or many of those orders are complete
crimes
so when i say all cops are criminal if
you are enforcing a law
that makes someone unsafe in their home
it makes them unable to fulfill their
second amendment rights
yes you are a criminal all cops are
criminals this is what i find really
funny there's like
some guy who argues to me on facebook
who clearly doesn't watch the show and
he's like you just keep saying the same
things your opinion never changes it's
just confirmation bias and i was like
that's not what confirmation advice
means anyway
there was a big change in my opinion
after you said that on the show
oh thank you yeah i've talked i mean my
stuff on 2a has gone crazy because of
the things you were saying
i'll i'll kind of second thing i guess
i'm an influencer now absolutely
like um so i guess you call you like a
powerful
social presence you you are very open to
changing your mind from the time that
i've known you you uh we'll talk about
things and then i see in like two weeks
you'll be like yeah you'll be
have different views if it makes sense
yeah and so you mentioned
that your right to bear arms shall not
be infringed and the police don't care
and they'll impress your right new york
city
and i said you're right about that and
so then my opinion on 2a got pretty
hey okay you know what fallon gets out
of prison give him his gun yeah
the right shall not be in french it
doesn't say unless you're a felon
doesn't say
there's a lot of things that doesn't say
but is it the argument that if they
don't uphold a criminal law
like go take their guns away that then
they have to leave the force so that
just by being there they're
part of a corrupt system making them
criminals or is it only when they
actually enforce
this they're legal so many laws that are
complete crimes to enforce i can't even
get like drug laws absolutely
this is the thing eric garner when
conservatives often point out that he
wasn't
choked when he i can't believe they
can't breathe you know and he died
because of a heart condition it wasn't
that he was actually physically choked
by the police fine
the point is if there's a man selling
cigarettes
and you feel comfortable walking up to
him putting your hands on him
and taking him away to a jail you are
the criminal
that that's absolutely to me insane like
dude the guy was
what are they called singles lucy's
lucy's and he goes officers i'm not
bothering him leave me alone he had it
you know he wasn't fighting them
he was resisting in the rest of the
sense that he's like i don't want to
leave get your hands off me
he wasn't he was huge he wasn't hitting
them he wasn't putting them in danger
the only person in that whole situation
who went to jail was the guy who filmed
it
right right right and that was crazy why
did he go to jail
i mean it just to me i don't want to get
too conspiratorial but it really sounded
like they're coming
it was retaliation that's what it
sounded like i mean you've seen i'm i'm
sure you've talked to us before but i'm
sure you've seen several things in
occupy
where the the journalists who are
covering it the independent journalists
are the ones they're being targeted oh
they're showing things that the
cathedral doesn't want
what what the city of new york does it's
brilliant they issue press credentials
from the nypd which is against the first
amendment
absolutely and then you can't get a job
at many of these news outlets unless you
have it
and if you get it taken away you can't
work there anymore because you can't
report so what would happen is during
the protest the cop would be like
they'd walk up to a journalist and say
if you don't leave right now i take your
pass yeah and they go bye-bye and they'd
leave
and then there was independent reporters
oh absolutely i'm not talking to the
audience let me just think about it you
know luke luke
you guys know me love him he did his
video where he filmed one of the most
notorious cops who would go after the
press and things like that
as like a nature documentary you know
this guy in the wild and he would zoom
in on him and he saw it and one day was
like you're the guy who made that
that video about me on youtube and
listen what you're talking about
but like you know the regular press
couldn't do these things
right because they'd lose their
credentials and they're not interested
because then further
doesn't further their narrative dude the
the abc would like pull up
walk out of the van say okay here's the
part turn around and say we're here at
the park here's what happened have a
nice day get back in the van
and that was journalism i was at
charlottesville while it was going down
and we were at um outback steakhouse
with like some of the alt-right people
and the surreal aspect
of what was a block away from us and how
it was being presented on the news
was such a red pill moment that you're
like looking out the window that you're
looking at the screen and it's a
complete disparity
that's that was scary to me when i was
in sweden the next week oh yeah of
course yeah
when all of the journalists aligned at
the same time to claim
all of a sudden just they loved me and
then the moment we
we got off the highway and turned and
went straight to rinkaby then they were
like uh-oh
and then every news outlet was like tim
paul's a liar a manipulator at the same
time
could be it was a it was it's a it's a a
poor neighborhood a somali migrant
neighborhood and so i was very much in
line with their potemkin village
the green party guy walks me around
everything's nice we explained like you
know what
these reports are just not true they're
exaggerated
and then i was i did my job i reached
out to a bunch of other people i talked
to some crazy people some regular people
some left some right
and we went with this one local
journalist and then abruptly he was like
you want to go let's do it paul's off
the highway and then all of a sudden i
was like uh-oh
he's not supposed to be getting off that
road and then the media just aligns
like the truman show creepy it is like
the truth it was creepy
we had people spying on us we had with
people lurking around our hotels wait to
like leave
all right i gotta read some more of
these we got elevate fitness dallas says
tim wish me happy birthday
happy birthday elevate fitness dallas
thanks for the super chat
um james asks i'm not sure i understand
this one he says i love that when i came
in i see michael malus dressed like
clark kent
and now at the end he is superman i love
him and i love you guys
i don't know he's talking about yeah you
are superman to me you know what this
is no no no no no it's this this is tim
you got troll these are the april fools
people
who get in the super chats they make you
to read nonsense and then you look like
a
fool reading this
you're kind of like like clark no no no
no no hold on hold on because he's
calling me a journalist he's saying i'm
one of the bad guys
clark kent was a newspaperman no this is
his backdoor way of making fun of me
he's complimenting you
he's saying that in the beginning he saw
he was a regular guy and by the end of
the show he realizes that you're a hero
who's fighting the good fight
oh that was what i thought okay yeah
that makes you agree
well i still think you're you're not as
bad as trevor but you're pretty terrible
all right we'll just read a couple more
because we just my friends i thank you
all so much for the super chats we just
we just have so many coming out thank
you and um all right let's see
patrick says what worries you more
cancel culture or compliance culture
what's compliance culture i guess he's
saying you know getting
banned or the people who just give in
and do what they're told
i don't know what he means by worse but
in terms of which is more a threat
to me i'm in no danger of complying with
anything
uh so it would be uh cancer i i don't
think these things to these two things
are super bowl at all i think they're
very much compliance culture
is cancer culture being implemented i
i i should i say real quick we got some
more super chats people
i i think they're really digging your
ideology they must be big fans of
anarchy okay or anakin some of the
things
they must really agree with your ideas
about defunding police and police being
criminals
because all of a sudden they're saying
things like we got crystal meck he says
i walked away for one hour and suddenly
your guest turns into superman
this is what i get for walking away i
mean clearly
your ideas are resonating with the
audience to where they they they just
listen he was a hero it's been tough
growing up for me being this
farm boy in the middle of kansas and now
i get to be in this
here in springfield illinois you know
with tim full
and all these other people so it's it's
kind of right it's very humbling
all right official jim says you opened
my eyes to politics tim how would i go
about trying to learn and understand
more where should i start
i don't know um you can watch my show
and then watch other shows
watch michael malus's show watch people
like jimmy dore because jimmy will give
you a more leftist perspective but he's
a he's a real guy he's an honest guy
very red-pilled leftist
yeah absolutely what is he like and he
hates war
absolutely that's my that's my criterion
are you someone
who even if you're like sometimes you
have to have war do you think this is
really a very mixed blessing at the best
of circumstances or are you like
we got to do it this is the big divide
for me when tim when you get up in the
morning what's your methodology
of sourcing news like what are your
first few steps
i just start reading a bunch of news
like do you have specific places you go
a bunch of different news outlets
twitter so my twitter feed is
a collection of left and right and
mainstream news sources and so i scroll
through that as soon as i wake up i'm
like scrolling through all these stories
you there's a website that lets you
judging by your twitter what percent is
right left and centered
i'm left you're left mine was 30 39 41
and then 20 percent centrist but it says
the news you interact
yeah which means things you're making
fun of as well yeah i so uh here's the
issue
i use newsguard on purpose to make a
point
and that means i'm often fact-checking
these certified sources and avoiding
many conservative sources because
newsguard is biased
so what ends up happening is on this
thing it says i'm i'm
interacting with more mainstream or
left-leaning stories but in reality it's
just
let me correct this it was ground news
says tim poole interacts with left-wing
stories but in reality it's just
mainstream news sources
so you think about what that really
means right right because i follow a lot
of conservatives and i tweet a lot
at conservatives about a lot of things
or retweeted by shapiro earlier
but the stories i tweet only come from
that check mark which is funny
so newsguard if you're listening take
into consideration about what that means
about your service the stories i
interact with have to be certified by
you because i'm trying to make a point
and then it claims i'm left biased and i
have a blind spot for the right it says
wow all right one more super chat
garhant says tim i respectfully disagree
with you creating a network of you
what will work is for you to form a
network with people like you crowder
ruben gadsad weinsteins
that is how you win bigly i'm not
creating a network of me
i'm creating a network with a bunch of
different shows
so i'm talking to comedians about
helping them do a show
there may be a comedian who is producing
you know anti-woke stuff or just comedy
that's just not
in the in the culture war at all just
funny jokes or maybe it's offensive
and we're going to give them an
opportunity to make new content we are
going to grow it's not going to be a
network of me
it's going to be original movies with
nothing to do with me we are going to
make this like
you get an app and you open it and
there's going to be you know a show with
a bunch of different people
maybe we'll do a michael malus comedy
special i would love to see that yeah
political comedy something like that
yeah have you done did you do live
comedy
my first job uh first trying to be
creative was doing stand-up this was a
very long time ago
and because i had a friend who killed
himself and we basically make because we
were so stressed about it we made his
that night into a roast
i thought to myself if i can do stand-up
and get people to laugh
anyone can make jokes about sex or
[ __ ] be texting whatever
if you can make people joke about things
like suicide then you're really talented
what i learned and this is why i quit
after six months
the same set that kills one night
will walk the room the next right and
you have no control over what lands and
what doesn't
and that was such a screw in my head so
much i gave it up
well then uh we'll see how this uh we'll
see how this
manifests but the idea is if you
remember at timecast.com we're going to
start producing a bunch of stuff we're
probably going to have gaming content
gaming reviews
we're probably going to have definitely
the vlog stuff but that'll be on youtube
as well
the goal is to just have a bunch of
different people involved and yes
you will get access to all these shows
the money that you are paying as a
member of timcast is going to be used to
build
culture that's my plan part of it will
be used hopefully soon
to start development on an open source
project we'll see exactly how we can
pull it off i think it's ambitious but
i'd like to do it
that being said my friends smash the
like button if you have not done that
already
show your support for the show subscribe
and maybe soon we will break one million
subscribers on this channel
with your support you can follow me on
all social media platforms at tim cast
my other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcast
youtube.comcastnews make sure you go to
timcast.com because we're gonna have a
bonus segment
up around 11 p.m with our good friend
michael malus and it's going to be fun
and spicy
and uh we do the show live monday friday
at 8pm so thanks for hanging out michael
do you want to shout anything out
yes we all talked about some funny
things today some serious issues and we
talked about support
so it's important to support the
underwear that supports you
are you doing a pro i'll get out of here
underwear
if you go to sheath underwear.com and
use promo code malice20 they've got the
dual pouch technology
and you could support the underwear that
supports me bridgette fedeci
dave smith and people like louis jay
gomez who will
you know won't make it in the uh when we
come to the next future i gotta get them
to send me a bunch of that stuff i have
some for you i brought some
oh wonderful so yeah protection i want a
swag box
right underwear in all seriousness
this is made by an iraq war vet okay and
it's independent businessman so
i'm glad i love being able to promote a
product made in america
um i was made in the ukraine
what does it say
yeah designed in america
design and the thing is if it's camo it
makes your junk even more invisible yeah
i think it protects you from sharks
right
maybe not that particular underwear i
don't know all right
i'm i was talking if i'm like i wonder
if i'm going to be able to pull this off
and you set me up perfectly
yeah oh and no no in all seriousness um
uh the anarchist handbook is going to be
done in the next couple of weeks and
that will be out and i'm sure i could
come back and talk about it you know i
would like to point out how cut you look
oh very ripped oh i like what you've
done with the body thank you sir very
muscular
for a 63 year old it's impressive yeah
you're towing the line
adrenochrome no no no not just a clever
myth
all right yeah you guys can also follow
me ian crossland.net which is my website
and you can find my own not that boy
scout nonsense
i tried another guy i waited to buy.com
for a few months after i started making
youtube videos and someone snagged it so
don't wait
don't hesitate or if you hate someone by
their domain name and forward it
i've done that trick several times
listen to the man
i love it i love it the superman michael
is the master troll and i love having
him on i have two things to say
i want to wish happy birthday to my pal
brenda today
april fool's day her dad must have been
shocked when her mom was in the hospital
he's like no i don't believe it
and the second is that i figured out the
mystery of what this term was that
that this hire liked so much about
michael mallett's
it was when michael malus explained to
lex friedman what
tits or gts
[Laughter]
so there you go that sounded like lex
luthor
i'm more of a brainiac please he doesn't
laugh though lex friedman that's true he
does it
so that solved that mystery i'm very
happy that i could help
i am sour patch lids on twitter and
mines and real sour patch lids on gab
and instagram
make sure you smash that like button
before you go and we will see you all
in the exclusive members only segment at
timcast.com at about 11. thanks for
hanging out we'll see you there bye guys
you